so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
you just threw in Bros tagline for that
or did he make it who's that tagline
isn't that from like it's a rappers like
perfect or whatever I'm using that for
like five six years I have no idea this
is Rob bro my homie this guy I know made
it maybe he's the producer I don't know
man it's been I just know that's from
Street Farm I guess perfect is it thank
you that's where it's from that's Street
Fighter yeah yeah it's when you get the
it's when you're messing when you like
ruin somebody with a whole round they
don't they don't touch you but isn't
that somebody's like tagline
audio in like a like I have the problem
I thought it was the same exact thing no
it is it's like right you isn't it um
Street Fighter yo
I like this episode we both went off
track immediately my bad Yo's usual
podcast uh thank you guys for being here
I'm with Marty O'Neill right here so
what's up guys let's hop right into it
you guys have been asking non-stop this
is the phase Rain episode thank you very
much for being here of course thanks for
showing up appreciate you before we keep
going real quick let's just talk about
this because it's my hand crushed grab a
leaf yeah man and it smells it smells
like my fifth grade camping trip to the
forest from my school's campfire bro it
just hits so differently you don't smoke
nicotine like a regular right at all so
that's gonna send you I don't feel
anymore that's what I'm trying to feel
what you feel like when smoking about I
just never get there again you dab
sometimes that's really rarely though
yeah that's some hash rise and then text
me tomorrow like are you right no I mean
with the nicotine specifically but even
with weed yes you mix it in with the
weed yeah so like percentage so it's a
blunt wait I'm trying to cut down now
because now it's just getting aggressive
I feel like it's even making me more
sick to keep adding as much as I do but
I don't know like not that much you'd be
surprised it's literally it's a little
sprinkle but it just packs a punch you
know what I mean because like I said I
have homies that own I won't say who it
is but he owns a very big dispensary
here and he makes all his employees
smoke backwards you're gonna smoke smoke
a back one save me the end and he'll
unroll it all the weed that's soaked in
that tobacco and you'll just spawn I
think that's insane he has a [ __ ] bag
of roaches especially collecting
everyone else's roaches all of it and
he's only smoking free save me your
[ __ ] roach that's what he like that's
the rule of the shot you save me your
[ __ ] roach that's interesting you
don't even pop up a weed he'll roll once
he won't join he just smokes that all
day is he okay that's what I like like
to know I don't know get it home
to get home yeah he's he's uh he's
living the life it's like you like this
yeah you like it that's disgusting
there's no way in the world that I've
never heard of that [ __ ] in my life when
I saw it I was just maybe your own
roaches that would make more sense to me
like weed together
backwards so like you don't make me like
the roaches it's like the nicotine punch
because he used to smoke punts non-stop
for the nicotine he's like I had to get
off it but you're not Adam L just dabs
roach or this one I know will roll it
back would press it like rosin squeeze
it and dab that you're lying no he's
like if you like can you do that yeah
he's like if you like blunts yeah it's a
little bit of extracted tobacco oil in
your dab goes
some people probably like the [ __ ] out
of that you probably like the [ __ ]
that's what I'm trying to do when I like
that I don't know that's pretty
crackhead you might okay it is it is
it's crackhead [ __ ] but that's what we
said about that I'm like almost there
you know what I mean when it comes to
nicotine I'm like I'm almost trying to
try that [ __ ]
no that's disgusting I used to do that
in like 17 when it came out because I
was like yo I don't give me anything I'm
bored of school yeah it's [ __ ]
watching one day you know what snoozes
I've tried that that's what it was
not put me on I've just tried it I don't
know exactly that's it comes in the
little pack though yeah I tried those
too because the thing that like turned
me off about like dip was like the
spitting like [ __ ] carry a
water bottle
then you forget and drink out of it
actually one of my homies homies did
that oh because I was like the first
person I saw in person like holding a
water bottle was dipping all day
drinking he was puking everywhere
there's no coming back from that yeah it
hit my lip once you drank somebody
else's my Uncle John's Coca-Cola bottle
it touched my lips
sorry guys let's chase Subs all right
hold on where are you from Toronto
Canada well Mississauga if you know the
area that I'm from Mississauga or
Mississippi
how do you think you smell Mississauga
before I give up I give up it's not i s
s i s s a u g a let's go hey all right
it's pretty similar yeah I just know the
song my mom showed me yeah it's the
Mississippi of Canada yeah what'd you do
growing up man
um
[ __ ] whatever any kid did you know what
I mean just you know [ __ ] around a lot
then I ended up playing a lot of video
games that actually just changed my life
because I didn't really get into video
like I played video games my whole life
but I got into it into it at like 12 13
14 before that I just always just be
outside just [ __ ] [ __ ] up like I
really mean that it's like vandalizing
[ __ ] I was like oh no me and my friends
are like bad kids we even want something
I did when I was a kid that I don't
think I ever even talked about but so
it's so evil like when I think about it
now because I'm like the biggest softy
for animals like like I don't know what
it is I'm just like obsessed with
animals and I feel bad for them all the
time it's like they're innocent I don't
know what's going on yeah when I was a
kid dude me and my friends one of my
homies used to have like hella like
explosives for whatever in his house he
was just I don't know dude he just like
not like stuff like that but it's like
firecracker [ __ ] like this [ __ ] to blow
up he just love blowing [ __ ] up for
whatever reason white kid of course yes
sorry Marty sorry sorry
and um bro I remember we tried making
lobsters once and it didn't work
crowded blew him up I hope you do that
in front of me I can't believe I did
that [ __ ] but that's you know what do
you mean it exploded like in the pan no
no no it was working so we cut bro
oh he was dead already ish oh yeah I
don't think he was homie you should do
crawdads and I used to catch him with
him and I remember he had his bike on
the seat and the handlebars he spun the
back tire at three went through it so
and I just remember watching like I
can't be here can't do this even in
general the way they make lobsters not
chill it's horrible I know maybe I don't
I don't really love this I can't watch
anything I'm like a borderline vegan
roof I look too deep into it because I
can't I haven't eaten in six years bro
oh you're vegan because of that
vegetarian or vegan fully damn bro
because I was coming off the Grapevine
and I remember I was like I gotta stop
eating me bro I love animals why do I
eat meat and I was coming off the
Grapevine and the sun hit the pasture of
cows it look all heavily like what am I
doing myself why do I do this and then I
I ate shrimp beef chicken fish which I
don't really normally eat and I got food
poisoning for like a week never had they
haven't eaten me since because I knew
like that's my sign to stop now yeah I
don't know what it is man look at animal
like
I'll eat the [ __ ]
no I can't do that yeah
it's crazy to me yeah so you're almost
there I guarantee you next time I see
you you're like it happened it happened
this chicken I saw on the road and it
said what's up and that was it I tell
you dude it's one little thing that's
gonna change it no sorry talk about
Toronto can we just say I'm from Buffalo
so you know it was cool Toronto to me
was the cleanest nice it's freshest
coolest City out ever yeah with Toronto
like a problem smoke joins no nicotine
Fiend I appreciate you though my brother
thank you sir oh so you really like the
naked yeah man I'm gonna have to hit my
roach maybe maybe one day this will be
different this is the second one yeah
then I go vegan with eating also vegan
with smoking yeah DJ goes like yeah
I'll gladly smoke this [ __ ] I'm sorry
can continue regular blunts too when
people pass around like blunts that
aren't spiced I'm like no I'm good
yeah oh okay so it's it's just in your
blood right in your ways yeah yeah it'll
go away it'll go away smoke non-stop
blunts too yeah sorry Buffalo yeah no
I'm just saying Toronto to me was sick
we went up there I'm like is it close
it's like two three hours I mean I mean
it depends how long they stop you at the
border Buffalo dude but it's like
Niagara Falls is right there yeah
exactly like Charles like an hour hour
half yeah the latest tonight it was it
was just I had gone to like Manhattan
and then I went to Toronto and I'm like
oh my God this is like a clean Manhattan
yeah was it awesome wildly dirty I hate
going back I was there yesterday there
was trash taller than me bro yeah taller
than my whole is that how tight [ __ ] is
you know what I mean I like it it looks
cool to look at it
rubbed to my shoulder as I walked by I
was like oh
you lived there for a while I lived in
Long Island for two years from like 2014
to 16 we lived in Long Island I mean
like the phase dudes oh you guys are all
from back east no we're all from like
all over like one's from Cali one two
are from Boston one's from Sweden one's
from Phoenix okay from Mississauga we
are very ignorant to this world you
before we started you said hex is the
one that showed me face what is that
even I thought you guys started this as
a whole well that's the thing it was
like it was founded by different people
but at the time it was like literally
just like a Cod and most of them left
before that Cod team even became
anything before yeah so they left super
early you know what I mean they weren't
part of the picture like super early and
then Tommy like temper he was like the
only one that was like a leader position
at the time and then me and Apex and
Banks and we all got brought in and
almost like pivotal time of phase but
back then it was just like you know they
just like it wasn't even phase members
full in their videos like even in the
original videos it was like just friends
it was just like they just made a team
name and like they'd even put friends
clips and [ __ ] in their videos so an
optic was already cracking at that time
like yeah she was doing their thing for
sure they were like pretty much the only
team at the time and then phase was
coming up for like trick shotting and
stuff like that just like no scopes with
snipers and [ __ ] like that and he
explained that to us it's like you're
running you shoot with a sniper and you
have almost no [ __ ] knowledge of
where it's gonna land yeah that's trick
shot but eventually yeah with the no
scope part of it but then the trick shot
itself like muscle memory end up like
going for the same shot over and over
again and it's like GTA when you [ __ ]
shoot Fool's off the side yeah part
three but one of those Founders his name
was phase resistance he was like one of
the OG three creators which was timid
house cat resistance and clips they were
like the three guys that like made the
name and came up with I think timid was
on that made the name but he left super
early like we even wanted him a part of
phase again he just was not interested
in this life at all and that was like
2012-13 his dad though made videos for
like five more years after that which
was [ __ ] hilarious shout out to his
dad I love you that's sick that's funny
as hell but um yeah so resistance's
sister worked at Dr Pepper Dr Pepper is
his sponsor MLG so she gave him tickets
to go to m I think it was like MLG
Dallas they drive over there it was a
member called phase magic and phase
resistance was the leader at the time
they drive over there they meet hex they
make a video with hacks hex shouts them
out I was I was like big into watching
like hacks and optic back in the day and
then that's how I found a buffets went
to phase then I saw tempers video then I
started [ __ ] my face yeah like back
then you know weird early 2011. and you
were already good what do you mean like
I mean yeah no I was good but I was
still like a little kid you know I mean
I was like inspired by all them and
that's like why I like wanted to I love
that though you never know who's in your
[ __ ] meet and greet line that you're
like we'll be working together in five
years you never [ __ ] know yeah we did
the math on it you were what like 16
when when you like got with FaZe Clan
yeah I was 16. yeah so is that when you
moved out to New York right away no that
was when I was 18. that was like two
years because when I first joined phase
it still wasn't like that nobody was
really like making money off it yet like
that like like the best person I heard
make money was 2 000 a month and I was
like because he had like four videos at
bang and he still only made two thousand
so no one's really like making money
like that yeah yeah not yet it was so
what happened
um it all started like because back then
the way it would work is like imagine
going for like a crazy trick shot like
sometimes it doesn't hit sometimes it'll
go a week you don't hit a shot right so
it's like harder to make videos you'll
only make a video once a month and it'd
be like a two minute Montage so I mean
back then YouTube was two hours every
thousand views so that was different but
um so you still like and it still wasn't
that good now they can go up to like ten
dollars every thousand views you know
what I mean so it's like even higher for
some people but um
what's it called wait what the [ __ ] when
did it change oh yeah yeah when we
started doing like live comps and [ __ ]
when we started like actually posting
every day that's like when it changed
you know what I mean because like
spending a month to make a single video
that's short it isn't really making
money like it's not enough yeah so it
started when you started doing like live
comms and [ __ ] like that you know what I
mean competitions no live like live
comms means like live commentary
like so we would like instead of just
showing the clip itself yeah we have
like a face cam and actually start
talking like live narrating the game
kind of like the three birth of reaction
videos come kinda but like you're
playing so it's like you're not like
watching your gameplay you're live yeah
so it's like you're not reacting to
after you're like during the fact so
when you hit it you'd be going crazy
yeah
commenting on yourself while knowing
what the [ __ ] you're about to do but
you're not like near it it's not like
you're oh it's not like you're casting
yourself over here now that I'm pulling
over to the right like that but it's
like yeah it's like you don't even have
to like do whatever I would just tell
stories and different [ __ ] while I'd be
playing whatever [ __ ] like that
basically what YouTubers do now yeah
yeah exactly yeah they show game Planes
to tell a story yeah so the loophole but
it works yeah our most popular dress of
all time Goblin that's what he does yeah
he just he's crazy I remember watching
one of his videos like a year ago
because I just said like drug tearless
I'm like what the [ __ ] let me see what
he's talking about from the most
wholesome looking American kid of all
time I know I just I don't know I guess
I was shocking that YouTube even like
let that video be up I was like [ __ ]
whatever yeah but it's I mean it's cool
that they don't be like that harsh
because like Instagram be taking down
everything yeah like bro I'll be
sometimes posting a story about a
recovery I won't even say anything weird
I'll keep it so big and they'll take
down my story I'm like damn bro it's
like we just met so you don't even know
but I'm on my 27th account on Instagram
number 27. I don't even post weed no
more last time I deleted I said pepper
did my mom yeah deleted so it's just
because you're trying to be positive I
promise I see the most negative craziest
[ __ ] just promoted and I'm like yo we're
just talking about like yeah weed helps
me sometimes [ __ ] don't care
Instagram is very uh I think he's the
last push before like okay it's legal
[ __ ] go yeah I feel like another year or
two I don't I don't know I don't feel
like it's going to be like that in
another year or two hopefully we'll see
but yeah and you're just simply showing
recovery and they're deleting it they're
not even be showing recovery it'd be
like speaking on it not even speaking on
it would be like text and I wouldn't
even put anything related to it I put
location that's available in stores or
whatever and I'll just say Reigns runs
and that's it yeah I guess oh yeah oh
the weed yeah they don't give a [ __ ] you
made money on it done that's how they
think they don't want any way to like
you know promote selling it buying it
anything even though I was like being
unbelievably vague with it because I
figured but still they're like damn
they're watching them for me just to a
big topic though
West Hollywood I want to say Bellflower
San Jose Pasadena actually I got them
yeah no uh when did it launch
um September 17th we gotta pop up and
barely call me on what's Hollywood yeah
oh comma I see that [ __ ] logo and
flyer everywhere I've never been there
yeah no I used to it's crazy because I
didn't I never like been to the location
before I did the pop-up there but I
would see it all the [ __ ] time
because it's like that pink building
it's like weed all over they have a lot
of the recognizable building yeah yeah
they're good at marketing spot actually
like for this one's pretty cool I like
it nice dude so how'd you go about that
you just said runs is my [ __ ] or did you
no we test your rating no we tested a
lot of streams obviously it's like white
label but we found like a good
cultivation that we really like because
it's going to cultivation out with What
it Took just so much longer and cost a
lot more so it's like you don't want to
be this like dip our feet into the
industry you know and just try it out
but because I've just I've always liked
weed and obviously I've always wanted to
get into the industry but I didn't know
how to then I ended up meeting one of
our partners Yoni and then he was
connected with the TP cup and then he's
like they were able to just give us
licenses and get us in nice yeah just
it's just yours or it's like a face no
it's not a facing no no it's just you
and my partner Quinn and yelling yeah
and then we also like have Eric Khan now
as a PO oh it's part of it yeah good
[ __ ] nice because he's over there with
pine part two yeah he's a fine Park and
that's cool he's gonna hacks and me and
this is like and hex is awesome too you
know what I mean like he immediately
congratulated me wanted to like get
together do something together work like
he's awesome you know what I mean he's a
very nice dude yeah yeah it's not not
even on no like he didn't even try to be
like fake competitive about her nothing
he just like Open Arms he's awesome yeah
he's a cool dude we
really knew who he was well Eric like I
said Eric and golf they pay game yeah
I'm addicted to [ __ ] video games if I
play I'm done I'm not gonna do [ __ ] else
that's why I stopped I won't play it
anymore three years four years ago you
stopped it Like Cocaine yeah straight up
I was like dude it's like a drug to me
like I I lost again I'm not gonna go to
sleep like wait what the [ __ ] at four in
the morning what game though Madden GTA
just stupid [ __ ] I played online for the
first time two years ago not for me I
don't like sports games online I like
playing with like people in real life
for that because there's this is laggy
dude I just I every I've never played it
and it hasn't been left no matter what
game oh like it's a gameplay yeah it's
lagging is that just a fact is that why
you don't I've never seen online sports
that hasn't been lagged it's always like
a second off like even to like I don't
know I haven't tried 2K 22 but 2K 21 was
like that like there's just no online
that isn't lagging I don't know why but
it is is this like Call of Duty the main
thing that people play it's like GTA
Call of Duty does it extended I mean it
depends like how what you classify as
main because like overall I want to say
League of Legends it still has like the
most players I want to say
I know Valerian is up there yeah I've
never played that either but that's a
huge in Asia right and then there's tons
of other mobile games that probably have
[ __ ] freakish oh yeah
I don't even know like I'm sure there's
gonna have a freakish amount of months
and they try to get people to promote
that game a lot yeah Clash of Clans they
asked me constantly sure you don't want
to put on your show like what the [ __ ]
is that because I'm pretty sure they
make a ton of money off like
microtransactions it's like the little
in-game things you buy a skin yeah
that's how it works dude it's the meta
you make a free game you get everyone
there and then you [ __ ] sell them the
cool [ __ ] smart the smartest thing you
can't do yeah it's the smartest [ __ ] you
could do Call of Duty is still behind
with that they're still charging for
like and then they don't even like worry
like I feel like they don't put enough
like money into their like design budget
to make cool skins because there's not
that many like it doesn't not one skin
has it felt like the fortnite effect
like bro I bought so many foreign
game it's harder to do with real life
maybe or like real life looking I don't
know so you're as a consumer you could
go hey Call of Duty change these six
things oh they would never listen to me
they don't give a [ __ ] about us they
don't give a [ __ ] what the community
says at all no not really they do them
they do them tomorrow Call of Duty comes
at you to be the project manager of
design you taking that
um I think I'd have to do for the
culture
I would never want to work for anybody
but like they would be like
the community needs it man that's cool
yeah no for real though like we need it
dog like I gave up so long ago called
this new game that was actually great it
came out when I was when I was gone so I
just saw the [ __ ] in Times Square of
like huge MW2 like face paint Billboards
and [ __ ] yeah that's the first game
that's dropped in like dude for me at
least like a decade that I like
since 2012 that was the last game I
liked that they dropped what games do
you play at home
does I still play Warzone like the game
that came out but I don't like it oh my
God you're like no this is fun I do like
it but it's just like there's things I
don't like about it's just I don't know
is it different I even consider Call of
Duty in a weird way even though damn oh
he's a different gamer gamer yeah I'd be
playing yeah my little brother's so
[ __ ] old he shows me he's 18. he does
the valve index [ __ ] and all the games
no the valve like the valve thing put
over your head oh like made his own
[ __ ] world he's Spider-Man stabbing
fools it's the dope he'd be on VR and
stuff you're saying yeah oh [ __ ] I said
about what you're talking about index
thing it's called oh is that what it's
called I don't even really know like the
Oculus Pro where the [ __ ] oh I don't
know it's the one above that he spent
all the money the games are cool enough
yeah I feel like it's such an early
stage for like VR that nothing's like as
cool like for the headset I don't know
it's like PS1 version stuff stuff right
exactly yeah the PS1 version of like the
I guess I'm waiting until at least PS2
yeah then I'll play PC till then when it
gets crazy on it yes or no you tell me
if you agree I feel like one day when
they put GTA in this VR we're gonna get
someone that kills somebody and go I
swear to God I thought I was playing the
game
and use that [ __ ] in court because
there'll be sometimes if I play Grand
Theft Auto for hours I'll go outside and
go driving like
yo you can't hit [ __ ] in this
life dude dude actually if you did it
like with your bare hand to kill someone
I'd say no because there's a car clear
different the card thing I could see
though that's crazy if you really feel
like you're in real life and you just
run over [ __ ] all day like you
really do pretend you go out you got I
don't know I could just see that
happening like right accident almost
that one's true because it's different
when you're like holding a controller
and doing it right or even playing like
a racing game where you can just see the
outside world but if you feel like
you're in and the graphics are so real
at that point to where they are real
Reigns be complex dude I couldn't see
that one I think it would be a direct
cause but I wouldn't be like you're free
but I'd like I understand you if I was
on that Jerry a little like
let's go back and deliberate
[ __ ] because yeah I feel him
yeah no dude it's real [ __ ] I think
about that but then I think of kids that
have been playing games their whole life
man like you said I used to be outside
[ __ ] [ __ ] up you weren't in you you
haven't been the gamer kid your whole
life I know a lot of kids that have not
left the [ __ ] room yeah I mean I
still played a lot like but this not as
aggressively until I got into like Call
of Duty actually hail Halo and then
that's like when I became a nurse okay
the show like I broke up with my
girlfriend I was a kid for the summer I
was like yeah I don't got time for you
stop swear to God I got back with it
when school started again and she said
yeah duh no I'm just kidding
I'm the number one good gamer at school
no it's not the dude actually it's crazy
this is I used to hide that [ __ ] like
crazy even like when I was making a lot
of money I still hit that [ __ ] stop it
yeah like I would not tell people that
because I was like is this embarrassing
dude I'm like YouTube God [ __ ] but then
now fast forward like whatever man I
know like [ __ ] are popping on
like YouTube and [ __ ] if they're in high
school like everyone's [ __ ] with them
crazy like no one's making fun of
anybody for that but back then I was
like I'm not gonna
you [ __ ] sell weed now
and then in college the ones that stop
being my homies in 10th grade tax the
[ __ ] Adam they started selling smoking
weed in college but yeah I got you 60
degrees 60 grams it was like 67 70 or
eight I was getting them at like this is
the fire one someone's a little cheaper
it was the same [ __ ] week they had
nowhere yeah my bad Brad
um but they used to make fun of me and
she's like you're a [ __ ] loser
because I quit the football team and
[ __ ] not because of weed just because I
quit the football team just happened to
start selling weed too yeah so they
thought like you quit to sell weed and
it's just the way it man so I feel you
like I used to hide that [ __ ] yeah yeah
isn't that weird like oh you're the weed
guy you're the coolest guy in school now
and you play games oh [ __ ] girls are
all over you like what nerd [ __ ] is okay
now it's [ __ ] weird now we were the
guinea pigs back then we was cool though
in Canada growing up even in like the
2000s right wait what like in Canada oh
yeah growing up like I was you weren't
getting pulled over in the car stripped
looking for it and [ __ ] like yeah I
smoked five times before like I was like
19 probably five to ten times I didn't
smoke that much before I like started
smoking and when I started smoking I
never stopped oh God she got you that's
a good question yeah what is it like in
Canada for the week our attitude to it
was like it was so much more Chiller
over there like from the New York side
of the bridge dude honestly I'm just
trying to think about every one of my
homies that got like booked for weed
back in the day they all just like most
of the [ __ ] that I remember the cops on
she just took that [ __ ] oh there was
like yeah because they were all kids
right so it's like the cops just like
took it tried to give him a life lesson
and then went and smoked it yeah for
sure yeah Officer Nelson Merced stole my
quarter I've watched him put in his
[ __ ] pocket bastard I don't care
Officer Nelson obviously everybody
that's his [ __ ] name Officer Nelson
[ __ ] you twice in one week he pulled me
over stole my weed twice damn I think he
just knew it's like that guy's got
[ __ ] fire I'm gonna pull his ass over
every time I see him free win free weed
yeah what are you gonna do call the cops
and say that [ __ ] like don't check my
trunk there's scales and pounds back
there take the quarter yeah dude [ __ ]
him
um okay hold on
range runs you're saying so eight or
nine stores out here I think it's only
like five yeah five yeah all right so
for everyone out there that wants to
smoke some wheat there you go so you
actually put your passion into that how
long did it take you to go
um I think we tried about like
50 or a little bit more than 50. and
then I was really [ __ ] with it but
then I kind of got hoed because they I
had to end up using a different Fino for
but it was still good but it just wasn't
the one I selected is it weird yeah it
wouldn't like be there on time yeah but
it is like I prefer the other Fino but
it's still fire you know what I mean but
I would call that one like a nine the
other one is ten for sure it's great bro
oh hell no oh good because you care no
because my partner Quinn like you know I
mean it's funny because I met Quinn
through Eric back in the day and um just
he taught me a lot about weed and so
what every person in the industry does
it kind of like cut costs and like you
know you know I'm saying like use bad
flour but then they'll use like dab or
Keith to like make it stronger it's like
they're using bad flour for like
pre-rolls and stuff like that oh yeah
just little things like that like my boy
Quinn he does not smoke payrolls he just
takes him and he breaks them open to see
how bad his [ __ ] they put in there I
sort of I've never seen him smoke a
b-roll in my life you only like breaks
him apart just to like from everyone
from Every brand so he just like taught
me a lot about this like all that stuff
like even like the fake dab cards like
what they do for that the way people
grow weed with pesticides what not just
he's very like gung-ho and like clean
flower and like clean product and not
selling anything that's remotely bad for
you so I was always like with that I was
like helping you curate in the back end
of course yeah
me and him do everything together when
it comes to like like weed selects when
we were like trying all the samples and
everything so yeah you need that though
yeah no he's a man for sure he was
getting the Video Game World you'd be
like yo so help me out a little bit yeah
yeah no so I understand like it's not
that like oh this guy's making the
decisions like no he's helping me along
the way yeah I know where we're all like
me him and you and you're all like equal
Partners we're all on the same that's
what that's what I do with my I have a
brand the dopest have you ever heard
like alternative cannabinoids
um you ever Delta nines Delta eights
yeah okay so those what's Delta nine
they're Delta 9 is like a form THC it's
I just mix that in there because it's
just CBD Delta it's like a CB I don't
[ __ ] with Delta a it's it's just it's
kind of like a placebo okay there's five
other cannabinoids that work really good
and there's one hhc that I made a
company of
but the way you're saying it's like you
know I have somebody helping me my
friend Hash House he's got a big
hashbrand he's a snob I'm a snob yeah so
we've been curating all these things AJC
is shippable to all 50 states
it gets you [ __ ] high no no it's uh I
would say I guess there are deltas it's
Delta 11. like it's the new one because
everyone's are Delta ten they'll do this
it's hard to explain but it is CBD
it's its own cannabis it's a cannabinoid
there's CBD we mix in CBD with it okay
CBN cbg's too but you're saying you can
sell it in every state every he saw it
online too door-to-door
then why is it not illegal then like why
is it federally not illegal it's not
teeth it doesn't okay but it gets you
high oh yeah what yeah
yeah I'll give you I'll give you a box
to take home try it careful with the
edibles
you're strong as [ __ ] yeah Edibles [ __ ]
me up I've had a tolerance to every drug
possible but not I can't say that
because there's [ __ ] crazy drugs out
there but you don't take this whole
that's our little new box inside is all
the stuff hella high club I'm sure this
is [ __ ] that would destroy me yeah the
Edibles the Edibles be careful with man
when you go no I know Edibles kill me
thank you brother yeah and then over
there oh yeah no I explained to your man
because I have mushroom nipples over
there and I put them in another spot
because
I have real Edibles over there it just
look like butterscotch yeah I just don't
want people on [ __ ] mushrooms now
could you imagine going to a podcast
that's like eating one of them
[ __ ] there's a pile of rappers over
there and then it hits you on the drive
home like halfway ones oh no that would
suck we [ __ ] around you just slowly look
at me accidentally had an episode on
them the other day yeah we ate way too
many Edibles on an episode the other day
I mean Mushroom on the episode the other
day
damn you're not you weren't this is your
first time being on shrooms on a podcast
no we've done it a few times but this
time I was too I feel like I would not
want to be on podcast I was on shrooms I
feel like I just say something stupid
I'm just hyper aware of my pattern for
going too much in here you see the wall
oh yeah I've been staring at home the
whole time yeah right right yeah but I
just all the greens I told Morgan all
the greens came out and like all the
other colors were fading and it was like
neon lights and I'm like I'm trying to
do a show [ __ ] so it wasn't that fun it
was definitely [ __ ] distracting yeah
it was with Josh Wolf Josh and Jacob
does all your [ __ ] get age restricted
um
we're trying to work around that I tried
to say [ __ ] in the first 10 minutes and
I tried to smoke too much weed in the
first time nothing just swearing is what
age is tricks now I think that just like
gives you sometimes not suitability for
the ads but I don't think I'd ever we
haven't been age restricted the past
like dozen episodes which is really
great we've implemented some light
censorship Spotify doesn't age restrict
us at all they love us across the board
but YouTube We're just trying to like
try tiptoe yeah because you know oh yeah
what they want yeah cause I'd be the
leader in this day on YouTube before and
he got my account back so YouTube were
like like we're walking the edge with
him we have three channels basically so
just in case dope is Yola Channel which
is his main one that historically has
always been age restricted oh yeah my
Ouija
always our past two videos weren't right
yeah they monitored that's like Eric
[ __ ] too I just talking to Eric about it
because he he gets it bad
I get it bad man yeah yeah they they
[ __ ] play they delete Erica
constantly on Instagram yeah when I just
got all this [ __ ] disabled yeah and
Instagram has like one like burner one
right now it's me I don't post weed
anymore on Instagram I don't [ __ ]
talk about it I want to risk it no I
mean the past eight accounts I haven't
still get them all deleted somehow we
started our own app we should do an
update about this yeah place to post
whatever we want double Zola app because
they'll send you a text like yo new
video out if YouTube might not send that
yeah but our app will so it's a little
Loop just to try to get around the
it helps man Shadow bands it helps it
helps as much as we can you know
um so I want to ask you a question as us
being mad ignorant I said to the video
game Earth I went to the Call of Duty
World Championship thing and like I was
telling more like [ __ ] are
lining up getting autographs like like
that's Dwight Howard and [ __ ] Fool's
head jerseys
I was so happy to see no that's right
it's so funny if like you don't know
about it then you pull up so you see
like gamers in Jersey signing because
that's yeah bro I didn't know I walked
in because text told me he invited us
I'm like ah I'll go I'll check it out
and I got there I'm like there's nothing
outside is this gonna be wag walk-in
packed I'm like oh they're they're not
drinking and getting high outside like a
football game I'm not used to a stadium
of people acting civilized and [ __ ] but
I walked in and there is chanting and
there's people cheering and there was
people on stage playing [ __ ] games on
screens I I was hyped and I didn't even
understand what the [ __ ] was going on I
was hyped oh it is cool it's a cool
environment just to see like all the
passion you know and everyone just like
I don't know they get really into [ __ ]
so if there's 80 people in FaZe Clan how
many people are doing like that
competitive style competitions half half
40 people yeah because I'm pretty sure
it's no hold up I know the roster
actually gives you the exact number
we've gotten a lot now so it's a card to
keep track of exactly people but I want
to say it was like because if you click
on all it says like yeah there's like 40
content creators and like 40 Pros I'm
pretty sure maybe even more Pros because
we have a lot of teams right like 60
pros and it spreads across different
games probably even more honor we just
have so many teams now and obviously
it's like we've gone that big we don't
obviously individually like love every
single game that we have pro teams for
but it's just all part of these Sports
you know what I mean I want to take them
all that's smart so there's a there's a
there's like an event for each game
championships oh my God yeah dude
there's like there's so many games right
oh yeah Call of Duty Championship what
am I saying yeah there's so many
different games with like there's like a
street fighter Championship yeah but
they're smaller you know what I mean but
there's even like rocket league if you
know what that is it's like cars cars in
soccer yeah it is that yo you got to be
badass yeah there's OverWatch Halo Call
of Duty even like FIFA had compared to
have a competitive player you guys took
in first place at different games
multiple games yeah absolutely yeah this
is this is the way this is crazy so if
you're a faith Phase Clan content
creator that like what does that mean
for the content you put out if you're
not a gamer it I mean it could be
anything you know what I mean it used to
just be gaming like it hasn't been
strictly gaming since like [ __ ] I don't
know 2014-15 but then we when we moved
in together like our the [ __ ] that we
found getting like the most recent
popped off the most was like our real
life content which had nothing to do
with gaming yeah but it was like our
foundation was gaming where we come from
his gaming Our Roots again it's all of
our fans even though they'd be watching
real life [ __ ] they're still Gamers and
[ __ ] but then people watch me that
didn't watch video games at all you know
what I mean so like you just end up like
you know branching off and getting that
entirely different fan base so we kind
of you know we mixed it up when we
started like personalities yeah it
started it became more about that
because that's what I realized was like
unless you're like the top three best
Gamers you're better off banking on you
being like funny or something like
because it's like dog people don't care
about the 20th best gamer if you have no
personality no personality and you're
the 20th best why would I watch you I
could just watch the first top three oh
so it's like if you want to be big in
content creation and you just focus on
being like the best gamer then you are
gunning just to be the top three because
it's really like I'm telling you it
doesn't really like pop like that unless
you know you have something you have to
be a little bit funny or people have to
like your optimism About You Happy
Gilmore like shooting mcgavins the best
one he's got three people in line happy
Gilmore's over there with [ __ ] a
crowd yeah like you better be Happy
Gilmore if you're not shooting mechanics
yeah I mean one of the biggest like Call
of Duty content creators has
historically like he's in faith it's Jeb
but he's like he was never there for
highlights he would actually put low
lights up he would have been [ __ ] up
yeah him to screaming and he's always
been one like for a decade strong he's
been the most consistent like Call of
Duty Creator like pulling numbers so
it's like it's about him people love
Jeff they don't give a [ __ ] about his
gameplay so it's like you would rather
that happen anyways because that's
almost how it went with me please just
cared with the trick shots and I was
like I need to do something because then
I have to always hit this [ __ ] or also
they don't give a [ __ ] about me you know
what I mean so like that's kind of also
why I started transitioning doing other
stuff because I didn't want to have to
do that every day in order to get a
video because you have to get lucky
there is like a luck aspect to it and
sometimes it was stressful as [ __ ] I
can't imagine man you know sometimes you
just say on a dry streak like that's
life sucks you're not hitting [ __ ] hit
markers [ __ ] like that but you seem like
you have such a connection with your
fans like it's different than you know
we kind of evaluate everybody that comes
on and yeah look at what they have going
on but it seems like you and your fans
are really tight and yeah I mean because
I I would the only I mean what people
have also told me like all of them are
pretty much told me is because I've just
been super open about everything you
know I don't really like have an image
to protect gotcha so it's just me out
here like I don't have no images
I don't care like so I think about it
yeah though could you imagine going to
bed going what did I say today in front
of who all right cool I gotta be that
guy for the next oh that's what I'm
saying I could never imagine that's
stressful so it's like that's always
just been my thing is it's like I don't
have like I don't like cap on [ __ ] I
don't like need to do that it's like
whatever it is it is like I went up to
it I don't give a [ __ ] and the thing is
what I realize is like everybody makes
mistakes this other people are better at
hiding it you know what I mean some
people want to hide it and they'll sit
there judging I can't believe that guy
did that meanwhile in the back they got
like
I did worse that's why I feel like when
the internet Purge happens a lot of
people are going to be a lot more
understanding because I've always been
saying one day and I think [ __ ] Tick
Tock didn't be the one to do it I just
feel like one day everyone's info is
gonna leak everyone's what do you mean
just every everything we got on our
phone everything's coming out
oh I don't know why I just feel like it
hasn't happened yet it's gonna happen
then everyone's gonna be like oh wow
we're all weird I hope that day comes
and they go let's look at Thomas oh he's
yeah he's just High yeah here's my phone
where's my password I don't care that's
gonna be a great day like everybody's
gonna do this it's gonna be that's what
I'm gonna say it's just like if someone
even tries to talk to it some of those
pull up their receipts like remember
you're watching three in the morning one
time yeah [ __ ] you you know that I never
I just feel like Monday and since like
you hear about like Tick Tock and having
everyone's [ __ ]
I don't know it's pretty freaky
um
I never thought about that eventually
freaky [ __ ] about what they do with the
information from Texas
I sent him tick tocks constantly because
we see yeah I see some funny [ __ ] and
then the only reason I like that app
because it's like you know what I want
to watch motherboard show me funny [ __ ]
if not don't even if I can put this app
on they cater to whoever's on the phone
man I will say that it's just endless
content on there because every type of
like genre content is on there it's
sometimes I'll be watching my you know
go through my likes and you can go
through the likes of someone's [ __ ]
abgo
it would probably be friends it's even
funny because like on a subconscious
like time investment level you feel like
oh it's just 10 seconds I can watch it
tick tock who cares that's what I'm
saying you'll end up watching two hours
worth of 10 seconds three days ago I
told Rosie I'm done being on my [ __ ]
phone I don't like I'm done scroll I'll
be on my phone like an hour went by
I feel like a piece of [ __ ] even though
you miss your homework like I could have
done my homework and do my homework but
that's why I like personally [ __ ] with
YouTube shorts because I don't know
what's good with my algorithm but mine's
actually like like whenever I was on
Tick Tock I'd feel like I just see
stupid funny [ __ ] that wouldn't like
nothing I wouldn't gain nothing mentally
from that at all but all my [ __ ] on like
YouTube shorts is like I don't know like
[ __ ] about like Jeff Bezos Elon Musk
Bill Gates Steve Jobs like Mike Tyson
Muhammad Ali Kobe Jordan I don't know
this like cool [ __ ] I don't know that's
what you say that literally everybody
your name is always on my YouTube shorts
yeah they're always showing me like yeah
that's how you're gonna make it and then
top G stuff you know what I mean oh geez
top gee you're not familiar
top she's a rapper really I'm sorry
Andrew Tate oh I know who that guy is
yeah gee man bald dude
I don't really get on the internet like
that whenever I see [ __ ] training I go
almost all of it you didn't see him like
all over your [ __ ] when he was like he
had like a run dude wow he had like do
that like
um because he made some sort of thing
called like Hustler's University or
whatever and like part of the program
I'm pretty sure was to promote
it and then like you would make an
affiliate code off people that signed up
so then the people that were in the
program it's like you know pyramid
scheme right middle school he did his
thing yeah I saw I saw a couple clips
and we go oh so he's a character yeah
wait two months and then when we start
talking about it differently no he's
really like that but he just like what I
think is like he just says like I would
have pocket things for the shock value
just to get people to listen and then
he'll start saying some real [ __ ]
because he actually knows what he's
talking about and like shock rep yeah
rap value shock value but he obviously
does know what he's talking about but
even people that don't like him like you
can't listen to him but they won't
listen to him for a few hours even
listen to you know so they'll think like
he just says super misogynistic [ __ ] or
just like which he does and he'll he
said something crazy yeah
but a cartoon yeah but in that sense I
feel like he's being a comedian but it's
like hard to tell the difference when
you're trying to act like you're
spending all the time but then being a
community that's like you know I just
like a guy smoking a cigar ball guy and
then just a bunch of people being mad at
me what did he say and I watch you go
he's just a 1950s like a macho man that
he could say anything he wanted with no
repercussions you mean just living your
life I don't watch him then [ __ ]
I don't
just don't watch it could you imagine
getting butt hurt like could you like I
don't know
your butt hurt about like somebody's
saying somebody that I never met
borderline if you [ __ ] on the Internet
it's crazy too that they like banned him
off everything I saw that he got
canceled like Allen that's freedom of
speech though people this [ __ ] whether
you like him or not you shouldn't like
that that's freedom of speech because
it's not even like he like I get it if
somebody's like guys we gotta meet up
here and do this and like they're trying
to cause crap or whatever but he didn't
do anything other than have a lot of
people like him and agree with him and
then social media think that's a bad
thing but that's just like people in
general agreeing with what he's saying I
thought I missed something he's not I
mean but that's just also a difference
of opinion but yeah yeah it's just
Freedom you just not watch it I feel
like almost now even like me saying that
it's kind of like how old [ __ ] was with
Trump back in the day it's like if you
even like speak on it's like you're on
his side and yeah there's a lot of
division between that too now
it's just yeah
now that you say that yeah he should
scream that I've seen a video of him
screaming that and saying people that
smoke weed are dumb or some [ __ ] I went
oh no I [ __ ] with this guy I'm out of
here and that's what happened I saw that
and went I don't know who this is but
I'm good yeah the thing is with weed is
like it can be great for people and it
can be bad for people depending on like
your perception with it you know in the
way that you sure for me I always tell
people it's like if you don't have a
routine in life and all you're doing is
smoking all day because weed makes you
comfortable right and here that just
makes you comfortable and also enhances
how you feel so if you like are just
comfortable all the time you're not
really getting those feelings of like
boredom and stuff that make you go out
there and get [ __ ] done so it's like
that's a great way to put that out it's
not that you're lazy it's just you're
comfortable with being plus like
complacent so you never even find
yourself being bored that often because
anything is good enough you're just
comfortable so it's like if you need to
do [ __ ] with your life it's like I
always will be like just cut down the
smoking get your routine in place and
then everything yeah it's everything
just if you have a routine like look at
you you're getting work done you're
doing podcasts all the time you're doing
it's just about to reach dude
but no I mean like you're getting [ __ ]
and you're a functional smoker you know
because you have your routine but if you
stop doing everything and you you know
started smoking all day and like you
just wake them be still all [ __ ] dead
maybe harder for you to get motivated
again it's true it is true because when
I was selling packs all I did was sell
weed from [ __ ] 18 to 20s I won't say
whatever 20 something all I do is
selling packs and I would smoke two
ounces a week with my homies and all day
do nothing so we eat sell packs sell
eight cells
but it's also different when you're
selling drugs because it's like there's
nothing to do customers coming in and
out right so it wasn't fun to me though
yeah like now that I think back like
what I do watch more compilations on
[ __ ] YouTube every day all day I was
making money but was I really like
stoked no no there's no fulfillment no I
couldn't leave town because somebody
else might get packed with somebody else
better price that guy's gone I can't go
to out of town I'll make I can't do
anything I can't go here he has to be on
call like it's three in the morning get
up for what if you go somewhere else
[ __ ] all right here because I tax that
guy I gotta get him it's never it's
never like fun so what you're saying
like it makes you comfortable it made me
comfortable with just making money like
[ __ ] it this is not port yeah that's how
I felt but as soon as I stopped like
what was I doing just sitting here yeah
so it's not the weed it was the
environment of my head of like no two
Zips because why not you don't need to
smoke two ounces a day yeah at all
nobody needs to you're smoking two Zips
a day one point yeah yeah I was so much
just to your face
by yourself no I had homies with me so
if I'm saying like if I'm smoking
non-stop probably like 25 Grand 20 grams
but like eight ten joints like just
power smoke you know what I'm saying
yeah I had a very bad face like that too
at least like a zip a day but not like
two Zips probably yeah it's too much but
it was like this non-stop rolling dude
that's my life and they got boring to
the point like I'm annoyed with rolling
[ __ ] so yeah I gotta sit here 10 minutes
[ __ ] now I don't mind the rolling I just
hate breaking up weed dude you can't
really use a grinder for like Blunts and
[ __ ] like that oh you had to do my hair
scissors no scissors that's crazy talk I
see my homies do scissors with uh
dutches they're weirdly lazy just break
it up
or the shot glass and scissors don't hit
the saying something about it I don't
know the way it burns I just I don't
like it even I've tried like a grinder
like just one two ha ha let go Grime
blunts yeah you just can't dude I can't
grind bowls and smoke them they taste
different it's like I could taste the
stem so you hang around for bowls too
never in life I don't hang grind for
bowls oh so you're saying like when
people grind weed up and take it out
random packable oh wait so what do you
do for bulls and I peel everything off
my finger oh yeah sometimes so you hand
grab yeah I'm saying like I only hang Oh
I thought you're saying you don't hang
around then you also don't cry no
because you're saying like if I grind it
tastes different if I grind a bowl oh I
can't smoke it gotcha I don't know what
it is yeah it's like there's some like a
little lingering taste so you don't
really use grinders at all ever I use
Grinders only for joints okay yeah but I
smoke a lot of joints the joints you
need it to be grinded right you have to
otherwise it'll like burn the paper
it'll I think of bless his construction
paper like it's stiff it's solid yeah
even if there's a hole in the side it'll
still hold shape if there's a hole in
this it's [ __ ] over it's Nothing's
Gonna fix it in life re-roll it like
it's done so that that's that's how I
like to think about it but also like
with joints like it's the same [ __ ]
little thing every single time of the
paper so you always get that same
consistent leaf with like a blunt it's
like every pack I open is a whole
different leaf with a different texture
with different stems it's a movie dude
you like it no I hate it
I wish it was like joint paper there's
like the same [ __ ] thing every time
like when I used to get blunts back in
the day and showed it was like a roll of
the dice if you could stay on one or a
fresh one it's just gonna just crumble
in my hands like I'm sure that's not a
factor but I remember that [ __ ] yeah
it's like it is like opening Pokemon
cards
and not for real it do feel that way
because you open it you know I've had
homies of smoke backwards and shingle
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right here we go like you
just lost eight dollars
yeah no I I like there's certain leaves
like you open you just know the leaves
like let me try to open one right now I
wouldn't be surprised if the leaf is
like trash
in this episode we've teamed up with
established titles and we're giving back
to the trees this project is based in
Scotland and did you know people that
have land out there are called Lords yes
guys 2022 and they're still using Lords
out there that's proper guess what Lord
dopasiola is here I have my own land in
Scotland guys with established titles
are giving you one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
Scotland each certificate has a unique
plot number on it that shows you your
exact plot and where it's located in
Scotland this is a global charity guys
every single donation or order you plant
one tree think about that you're
planting trees in another place for
restoration of the earth they even have
couple packs for you and your
significant other with adjoining land
what an astonishing holiday gift and
this is a little wild guys but Marty and
I have our plots anybody that uses our
link is going to get their plot in our
little sections it's called the dope as
usual Kingdom and it is in Scotland
right now established titles is running
their biggest sell of the Year their
Black Friday discount go to established
titles.com dope and get an additional 10
off again thank you guys so much this is
the first thing we've ever done like
this let's push some trees and plant
some trees
I'm hyped these knives are dope
Cami Koto high quality Japanese steel
using ancient techniques passed down for
many generations 19-step process to make
this knife and each one is inspected
this is like some Kill Bill sores but
for your kitchen yes you can go to
Walmart and buy a knife but why not buy
a knife that's gonna last you forever
and when I mean forever I mean it comes
with a lifetime warranty this is
literally the last Knife Set you're ever
gonna need each knife comes in this
beautiful heavy duty Ash wood box keeps
you safe and makes it even a better gift
when you give this to somebody before
they even see the knives you know it's
high quality you know it's durable these
are baller the seven inch blade is for
vegetables I didn't know that did you
know there's different knives for
different stuff the slicing knife right
here eight and a half inches long that's
for slicing and then you know the
standard utility knife down here five
inches these things are sharp chemicals
running a special Black Friday deal for
all the dope as usual listeners get an
extra fifty dollars USD off your
purchase with discount code dope on top
of all the other offers they have going
on remember guys that's kamikoto.com
forward slash dope dope that's our
discount code and that's gonna get you
50 off your set
I don't even have a new pack no no okay
so but I guarantee one's [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah that's why because I open them and
then I throw them back in because I
don't want to sleep I don't want to
sleep so I just open them and throw them
in
the worst I don't know but also the best
because you remember the days you're
like let's all throw in on one blood
no I never experienced that
unfortunately in life no fortunately
trying to find a hobo that looks nice
enough to actually buy your blunts for
you and not just take it that's the
largest you did great I promise I have a
homie that starts smoking at 21 so he's
never smoked hammer like average Never
Smoke bad weed and it's awesome yeah
like I think if you got this you've got
to skip it yeah good for you because you
understand just run from cops while
smoking cans in the forest no then
[ __ ] great
I have smoked from a can in the forest
but there was no cops chasing us in
there okay yeah but stiff like that yeah
like you know you missed nothing there
was experiences no I I remember for my
camera we're so kind of like a gravity
bunk of a water bottle and one of the
homies did that and then like I think
the other times was joint joint bombs
called it that's it really in high
school yeah in high school did you do
good in school if I had to ask that I
don't know oh I was on my YouTube [ __ ]
man school I put that in second place
like that's fine yeah that's fine and my
principal told me to drop out too so to
go to video games yeah oh I mean I was
making more than him as a dick or like
yo this is no and because like he had
like a good job with like this newspaper
thing in Toronto like back in the day
and um his parents made him stop that
because they didn't think it was gonna
be anything that ended up actually
popping off called Toronto Sun or
whatever and um so he like felt it to
like personally because like his parents
made him stop he's like now I'm a
[ __ ] principal dude
he wasn't gassed about it and um he I
dude I wish I remember what he said but
he said something like really wholesome
and cute I remember what he said but
like he said like something about like
school not putting you in a position to
have to go to college but it's to get
you ready in life some [ __ ] like that
yeah but he said it really beautifully
and like it just like you know resonated
with me too and like he just told me
he's like school's always gonna be here
bro this opportunity won't be like if
you say like okay I'm gonna stop this
YouTube [ __ ] go to school get my [ __ ]
calls and say all right let me try
YouTube again like that might not work
but if you try the YouTube thing for two
years and then that doesn't work schools
that's a [ __ ] building this is always
here it's not going anywhere so who
cares like you're on your time you don't
have to be on school's time so damn well
I'm glad man yeah dude if it wasn't for
him my mom would have been tweaking like
she even though she shut up because like
three months later I retired her so it's
like what are you even like oh [ __ ] in
high school yeah I mean I dropped out
within three months later retired her
yeah she's been like not working since
you were [ __ ] making money like that
young I mean honestly like now that I
look back at it I didn't even like I
kind of prematurely told her to attack
because I wanted to like but I didn't
have that much money saved up like
I could have like sold on YouTube like
yeah Mom sorry you gotta go back to work
that [ __ ] ain't gonna happen but I just
you know three months because I didn't
mean nothing you know I had no bills
that's like I don't the money can just
go there I don't really like that [ __ ]
like I'm what the [ __ ] am I buying
nothing so it's like I don't know damn
your mom's scored yeah she scored with
the side score
did she feel the same way the principal
did like hell no
supportive nah because she didn't
understand it and like what'd your mom
do for work she was a manager at a
dollar store oh so she's working working
like my mom
yeah
okay okay she always like be super she's
always like all of our biggest arguments
would happen because she'd come home so
mad and upset about work so it's like
that's why I realized like before
anything like that has to happen you
know good [ __ ] for your principal to
know you must have because you said you
were like keeping it a secret but you
must have been like oh yeah like at
school at a certain point no no I just
I'd never like talked about that I'd
only told that my principle was like who
I broke the news to I didn't even tell
my mom like how much I was making no
that's crazy
I love this come on sorry I avoid if
you're going into the principal's office
because you're in trouble he's new at
the time like one of them but that's
like nobody else were you in the
principal's office because you're in
trouble no because so what happened was
I had to um so I had a cooking class
right and they I had they wanted me to
take an exam with the examiner during
MLG Anaheim and that wasn't gonna happen
was MLG what does that mean it was like
a Call of Duty event that's when we're
all going to meet each other you're not
gonna miss that [ __ ] do a [ __ ] exam
you got me [ __ ] up so I just said like
I'm not can I do the exam early teacher
said yes then two days later he says no
he says never mind in case you give the
other students the answers to the test
I'm like dude I'm not I'm going to
California just like stop yeah and he
said no so if I didn't do the exam it
was like 20 or whatever so I like would
fail the class because I was barely
going to class anyways it was a [ __ ]
cooking class dude oh wait for oh Mac
[ __ ] no I can rock another day like it's
literally a cooking class whatever it is
I'm not gonna be a chef I guess I ain't
gonna be a chef whatever but yes I have
to pretty much like that credit he told
me I'd have to do summer school and I
was also just like not doing summer
school because I got way too much
YouTube [ __ ] to do so my principal said
honestly this drop out dude he's like
that just makes way more [ __ ] sense
you might be the only person ever to
have their principles tell them shut up
I'm sure you might have told someone
else if they're nah he didn't it was
just you I promise
get the [ __ ] out of my office that's
what he pretty much said yeah you're
making more than him in school that's
the love it
love it no it's it's great dude because
you don't see kids that actually any
other kid would have been telling every
single person every morning how much
YouTube is paying them he was hiding I
love that man I don't tell nobody it's
funny because the one homie that I did
tell about it he was like the only
reason I told him is because like he was
my age but he had more money than me I
was like how like he had like 50 bands
saved up at the time like in in uh in
like senior years on 12th grade what's
he doing saving his money since he was
six years old like he had like a dude no
no like if you think about it like if
you save everything you do every
possible job he's like a white kid oh
he's one of those kids that's what I was
yeah
every pause like you have no idea like
when I tell you everybody and his
girlfriend is entire like he had dated
girl for like six years and like her
parents were super strict Spanish family
so she wasn't allowed to leave the crib
ever you only saw her at school and he
was so butt hurt but all the time he
just worked to get time to go by so he'd
go see his girlfriend
I love that guy yeah he he came up on a
bag doing that so like for so long like
it took him I can't even imagine how
many hours he put in for that 50k like
he probably put in like dude
yeah I saw it it's like not even worth
it when you think about he probably got
paid a dollar an hour you worked [ __ ]
50 000 hours dude like like yo that
sounds like me
I didn't get paid [ __ ] like yo gonna
build that fence I think my Grandpa gave
me 50 on my dad but four days building
that fence
I remember what I bought I bought Blitz
got GI Joes I remember all this [ __ ]
yeah that's good [ __ ] yeah doing Blitz
with splits Blitz the video game
football game Blitz NFL Blitz you never
played NFL Blitz no I honestly don't
even like I didn't really start even
fake caring about because I don't even
care about football I fake care about
football
um to like dude this year
so who do you fake care about
It's gotta be there I guess the
Cardinals you know I mean he's in Fades
economy is in Fades so oh no [ __ ] okay
yeah so it's like you got this fastest
man in the NFL okay that [ __ ]
sucks no I'm just saying he's uh [ __ ]
fast or I think he's running he's
running like a bobblehead like his
head's first and he is so [ __ ] quick
I was just talking about him the other
day I don't even like the Cardinals but
damn he's fast yeah but anyway so he
fake care about the Cardinals I [ __ ]
with that yeah NFL Blitz was the best
football game ever as a child because
you could do whatever body slam fools
power bombs oh so it's like WWE meets
NFL yeah you it stops you with a line
but until but you can full Sprint and it
will stop you at the imaginary line and
once they hike you you're in but it's
like Street rules it's NFL Street
remember NFL Street a pre-nfl street
like it was badass I'm so happy I made I
just helped him a video game NFL Blitz
you should go watch play that game try
it someday but is it even on like
anything accurate or is it only on like
the oldest consoles possible I have no
idea dude I've been playing since I was
pre-weed oh well I don't know like how
many years you've been smoking
20.
20 flat flat this year bam
oh my God 20.
you're doing okay
you're live oh my God yeah starting when
I was 13. just sweeter like nicotine
this whole time too
no I smoked cigarettes for seven years
straight nicotine do you have a bong out
here was that buying yeah I got you hold
it through the Eric beep
we actually just released our own boss
huh like last episode we just put out
our own bongs oh did he pause it was
that beef like a fake beep that was just
a fake baby yeah I thought he clicked
something to like simulate a beep sound
we believe in the episode it'll go bleep
like in between arteries and [ __ ] oh but
he might you'll see when you walk out we
have like the on top of the box it's
just like this pattern on the walls here
but they're like modular so you unscrew
it so you can like wash them super easy
portable interchange the different
colors and [ __ ] so they're cool very
cool very cool yeah I'm not sure because
we just put those out but he also has a
company push trees which is a good
clothing line
and they have bongs and that's in the
warehouse and he's got the six foot box
hold on he's about to walk in here with
you challenge them to bring in some
glass and [ __ ] yeah you gotta hit this
[ __ ] too you smoke do you ever smoke
nicotine or no no I've never like I've
never had never smoke but then I don't
know if I don't want to you know take
your nicotine genity because you'd
probably puke you probably would it's
possible no yeah I don't I've said no to
[ __ ] nicotine so you've never smoked
a blunt oh no I guess I have I started
smoking weed with blunts like cigarettes
no yeah no when I first my whole Buffalo
stem you just meant like you know you've
never added tobacco to things you're
saying never got you got you got the
hookah
Kinda Yeah
I mean I'm taking like two Puffs off a
hookah like oh yeah okay okay
no that's good bro if I could kick one
thing it'd be the nicotine which I can't
I just dude yeah that's fine I just
don't want to dude it's fine
what do you have there I like that price
is right boys well what is that this is
our new bunk it just came out [ __ ]
stoked there you go do you eat
um no no I got you but this is for you
oh okay I got this uh first time ever
everybody knows I don't [ __ ] with
tobacco I'm gonna try it
I might not like it I'm just gonna say
that it won't like what it tastes like
probably but there's no way you don't
love how it feels
there's no way
I'm so juicy
there's no ways
giving me drugs and I'm 12. damn serious
yeah
dude I couldn't even like if I because I
used to smoke this other thing called
Doha it's like this Middle Eastern like
straight pipe tobacco thing dude that
[ __ ] is you said don't drive yeah like I
would just imagine like the profile did
this like in the middle of driving oh
you lightheaded and [ __ ] so lightheaded
like the most light-headed you could
I've never done it personally but one
time I did pass out slightly when I was
driving just hitting the weed too hard
so personally yeah it was me damn well
yeah I didn't mean to laugh while you
think while driving but like you caught
yourself that's why I get because I seem
like you oh yeah I came back yeah yeah
but you know those times you're like oh
my God [ __ ] I'm getting so light-headed
man roll down the windows and start
playing Skrillex or something start to
change it
play reptile or whatever it's called oh
my God nah dude it was uh don't smoke
yeah super bad so I heard you say in one
of your videos you like to microdose to
open yeah it's neural Pathways I do yeah
I did use the on was that I talked about
on the Ben Baller podcast no this was
out on your YouTube channel oh yeah I
used to like love microdosing but then I
got really sick from it I haven't done
it since so what do you what do you mean
open Narrow Path what are you saying you
like micro dosing because it expands
your brain well though yeah I mean
neural pathways are essentially like the
way that your mind does things in like a
patterns like the pattern of like the
way your mind will do things and
apparently psilocybin which is like the
main ingredient in shrooms apparently it
helps you move your neural Pathways and
like like you can change that not maybe
immediately but a lot quicker than it
would like normally because normally
you'd have to like manually adjust like
whenever you feel a certain way whenever
you naturally do what you do you'd have
to like manually adjust that by kicking
a habit you know what I mean like the
way that your mind is wired to you know
repeat that habit it's just like that's
what your neural yeah dude that's
awesome though that's like the benefit
of psilocybin that's why they say like
people have taken like acid and shrooms
or other types of type of psychedelics
and like kick [ __ ] immediately because
like they played with their neural
Pathways that's like what I like about
interesting so I was like you know
that's why I never understood why people
would like take psychedelics and party
because I'm like all sorts of bad [ __ ]
could I don't know I just feel like
that's like bad Marty
I just like any [ __ ] shit-faced and
mushrooms are the ultimate hey your body
is not your body right now yeah so
that's how I feel about it I go in the
dark when I take mushrooms I eat I eat a
lot of them I like six seven grams
usually and then I go in the dark you
ever trip to the dark no lights no music
that that's therapy bro really could you
imagine everything you want to start
hallucinating you can't see so your
brain starts like projecting it and if
it's pitch black imagine us being in a
pitch black room and using a projector
that's how I was looking at things like
I'm seeing it on my wall it's [ __ ]
awesome that's what should be good it's
a lot tobacco it should be good oh [ __ ]
this is uh oh I can't reach it I guess
yeah
foreign
okay I mean hey this is this is historic
you got this champ you're the only
person ever in life to get me to smoke
backward I mean to get me smoke to back
up there we go oh you don't smoke
tobacco normally like ever like ever no
buns ever oh like tobacco oh damn wait
are you better
that's interesting I haven't seen that
done before seen people smoke a joint
out of it
that's I'm assuming it's so he doesn't
have a butane
um
would you feel in your brain what the
[ __ ] it's in your brain right I just got
so light-headed right
yes
I don't think I've ever experienced that
Marty hit this all right I'm not gonna
start smoking tobacco but I don't think
I've ever been lightheaded like that
it's a trip
ah for a second I had to remember we're
[ __ ]
like six in the morning if I like wake
up out of my sleep and I hit it are you
like the only time are you like the
morning with it on the regular I try not
to be I try to at least give it a few
hours because I don't know this like I
don't know normally I'm just you said
smoking the second I wake up but now
it's like lately I've been giving it a
few hours yeah I like to get up at the
ass crack or Dawn and kick off early
with something oh he has three children
because it has to be a little different
yeah it has to be yeah three children
yeah that's fine so he's not like I'm
gonna get high first it's still darker I
gotta I gotta be mentally at a certain
place before anybody who's awake yep
before everybody's out they're like all
right I'm high [ __ ] get up for school
that got me so lightheaded for a second
I hope I shouldn't hit that and then it
went away
that's what I'm saying like in the
middle of driving it might be intense as
long as you're driving yeah
are you [ __ ] serious but it's
technically legal to do because like you
there's no rule against smoking tobacco
while driving a little puff I don't want
to cough my [ __ ] lungs out oh it
wasn't a coffer at all
what the [ __ ] I have never experienced
that in my life do you normally I had it
like that before no not off smoking weed
yeah
because it's not weed it should
all right
dude you got the baby experience with
you yeah yeah yeah it's a different head
feeling my homie that smokes the
backwood roaches it's a different
feeling not wine yeah after the
mushrooms I decided I could never be
[ __ ] up on the show again the issue is
like you can get like tobacco sickness
and like Nick sick and [ __ ] like that
sick oh you don't want to be Knicks
throw up The Sandlot you just feel sick
like it's just gross throw up oh [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah I don't know about that one do
you want to hit it now I'm cool oh
you're good I'm cool yeah there you go
can you put that down yeah
yeah The Taste definitely not there yeah
no no it tastes like that's also why
I've been like Tony then because like I
actually want to like you know taste the
weed yeah like it's lately it's been
like something burned and sometimes it
burns dude yeah I bet I don't know why
it's like real spicy I don't understand
why that got me so [ __ ] light-headed
because I still feel it just took a big
ass puff off it for the first time weird
man I've never felt that in my life I
thought that's what I'm chasing man
that's what I'm changing he's jealous
right now
[Laughter]
that's how I feel like you've never seen
the office let me show you [ __ ]
I'm like that with my kids Pulp Fiction
yep Dumb and Dumber yeah like you better
enjoy this [ __ ] no way well I'll never
Gotta Love Again Dumb and Dumber though
yeah that was the first all my kids
that's made me love my kids more
everywhere there were like seven they
had their own love for Dumb and Dumber
that was the first one yeah that
candidate oh so what's up Jim Carrey is
like the heart of Canada or what I think
it's like Drake now is it I think he
kind of kicked him out but Justin Bieber
kicked him out first I think oh he is
Canadian huh yeah we looked this up
there's there's hella Falls famous
people from Canada a lot Keanu Reeves
Mike Myers the week I knew Mike Myers
the weekend yeah I knew that obviously I
didn't know him he's still Canadian we
were the first person you said Keanu
Reeves Keanu Reeves I didn't know that
yeah he's from Toronto makes sense yeah
John we could only come from Toronto
John Wick the love for a dog could only
come from the love of a Canadian oh God
so [ __ ] true
what does Tim Hortons mean to you a
coffee shop dude I try to explain that
though but it's like oh your coffee you
always says the in and out of coffee it
is it is but I'm just not a dick rider I
guess but like a dick rider of coffee do
you drink coffee espressos in the
morning yeah I don't [ __ ] with it yeah I
need to find something that I can do
that other human screens here it's green
tea It's gotta be I drunk it nothing
dude nothing in the world works on me to
like wake you up except for drugs but
I'm not doing those it's crazy because
it has a little Adderall but don't try I
think Adderall is the devil I put
Adderall and Xanax on like meth level
because of like how bad they are for you
they're obviously not the same type of
drug but this you know no pills for me
do not not in my realm good yeah no um
but yeah that that tobacco thing oh no I
could feel it yeah I get what you're
saying that's not just weed no no no
sorry I'm trying to like recover from
this [ __ ] I [ __ ] ripped it I feel
like get back on you used to smoke
cigarettes that too so yeah but I smoke
cigarettes because I couldn't smoke weed
right then and there gotcha so I'd be
like [ __ ] smoking cigarettes you
should deliver pizza and sell weed out
of my car like a movie [ __ ] like so we
had my car
and I just put all my [ __ ] in my bag you
know walk up so we didn't [ __ ] leave
so I'd be smoking cigs I was the Nast it
was nasty God cigarettes are gross yeah
that's like why I smoke like started
smoking blunts like that because I would
never touch a cigarette they're just
they're terrible they're disgusting
there's like no other way for me to
smoke nicotine too without it being a
blunt and then you're mixing it with
some weed at least it's better yeah way
better absolutely it's 90 better than
food outside smoking on Black and Milds
but also I feel like the worst part of
cigarettes is like everything else than
the tobacco because there's like so much
the whole recipe oh yeah tobacco's just
like a part of it one four thousandth of
it it's like it's so much more pretty
sad yeah it's seriously alts but it's
like the base yeah but it's tons of [ __ ]
I was just explaining this to my kids so
I don't know anyway we got a quick new
segment here I want to test out real
quick what it's nothing big if you have
for the rest of your life if you had to
pick either one YouTube channel or one
artist music artist to subscribe to [ __ ]
who would it be well subscriber doesn't
matter no more to be subscribed like all
you're getting is that okay okay so
there's only one person a YouTube
channel or a music person and or
um just to kind of get your where you're
at with music or YouTube
[ __ ] it has to be the juice world
channel because he's got music forever
um bro wow that's an interesting answer
um
wow forever music oh yeah yes thousands
of songs they're gonna take forever
thousands yeah bro he like when he died
he had like 3 000 still unreleased so
he's like 20 years old you freak though
damn thousands of songs for you [ __ ]
yeah man yeah I'm not I'm not uh
familiar enough me either he's our fans
like number [ __ ] one person they
always fight are they they did 999s or X
and then they always put like well I
mean obviously say his name it's always
like the same [ __ ] everyone's [ __ ]
YouTube name is that yeah that's like a
lot of people that seems to be our crowd
on the background of Spotify of this
show like oh the audience is a music
yeah that's right oh and most of them
yeah no number one is number one oh
who's number two Drake Drake yeah yeah I
don't know about after that but I
remember seeing those two like well that
makes sense [ __ ] popular yeah yeah no
I get that but damn Marty for the last I
hope occlusion artist it's tough to pick
I gotta go The Beatles
damn I got well at least 12 albums I can
[ __ ] with so
I don't think there's anybody else I'm
gonna sit through that alone man do you
watch like we were talking about before
we started filming do you is there
YouTubers that you like maybe have been
subscribed to for a long time or you are
always I've always liked my favorite
like YouTubers overall just like
everything's on his KSI it's like
football KSI it's a dude from England
right yeah yeah dude I'm not on it I
know he boxes [ __ ] out of somebody
that's all I really know about I don't I
don't watch I just barely started
[ __ ] with twitch recently and who do
you know from twitch do you know who
ninja is gotta know ninja I know him
because he's Tyler they'll do with the
[ __ ] the blue hair yeah yeah blue
hair dude that and I know there's
another super big YouTuber uh PewDiePie
that guy that's all I know about YouTube
Mr Beast I like that kid he seems nice
other than that I don't know YouTube bro
like and people always ask well you
don't watch YouTube as a YouTuber like
bro I sell drugs my whole life happened
to make videos yeah that's YouTube was
just Worldstar fight comp that's all I
used to watch every Friday well star
fight comp I read that they're bringing
Vine back yeah Elon apparently told him
to start working on that [ __ ] really I
think Tick Tock kind of murdered that
yeah but also Tick Tock did murder that
but then all they got to do is just talk
more about the fact that like they
started broadcasting more on Twitter
about what they're doing with Tick Tock
and your security and everything and you
know it's them taking all your info and
all that [ __ ] and eventually I don't
want [ __ ] Tick Tock and it says you
know
yeah I feel like a lot of Americans will
start using by not the rest of them I
love Americans mine was the [ __ ] I loved
it remember the day they [ __ ] took it
down I was you could post weed [ __ ] on
there that's why I was on there they
didn't oh you could yeah but because
it's owned by Twitter right so Vine was
owned by Twitter yeah so they owned it
so and Twitter just does not care like
oh no [ __ ] there bro even like today
when I was looking because like take off
pass today right bro that rest in peace
when I searched up like his name is to
see like what people were saying like
the video of him dying it pops up it's
me you know what I mean like so I don't
know like Twitter shows or whatever yeah
it's crazy that people are posting that
[ __ ] on Twitter it's like Twitter's is
unregular it's like [ __ ] open Waters
yeah everything's on a porn everything
it's crazy
yes but it's everything it's like yeah
before you said it's like certain
accounts like those meme pages when I
used to this like I don't know post how
like only fan [ __ ] like I'd just be
scrolling this porn and pop up all the
[ __ ] time with my horny fans I used
to follow [ __ ] his retreat
a couple friends that do porn and [ __ ]
well I can't get on Twitter in public I
have I do this who's gonna post
something that makes me look like a
[ __ ] creep that's what I'm saying oh
[ __ ] oh okay we're good we're good we're
looking into it I never thought about
that oh man me and Rosie can't open our
[ __ ] twitters it's the worst bro it's
the worst
I stopped I used to love that like meme
where you click on a video like where it
would be like kind of low then you turn
it up
that's [ __ ] up
boom loud porn so people on buses yeah
just look I could imagine being in high
schooler with a phone right now bro I
didn't have a phone at high school I had
that [ __ ] at like 17. demon
everyone made more money I know that
well I had a phone but you couldn't do
anything but text a [ __ ] on it
so how did you get people back in the
day
only people I knew I always tell people
to weed to the people I knew and if you
didn't have a phone that no I'm saying I
didn't have a phone that didn't do
anything but text and shims and I think
it would have made more money like yo
check out this video [ __ ] oh
look at this oh he's still out I got
this yeah I had the Nokia like how would
they contact you so if they show up at
your door or are they no I saw we at
school oh I got you I saw most of my
weed at school unless it was the weekend
and I just went to parties to sell weed
to people yeah because everybody's got
ten dollars at a party and you're going
to party's business man I never went to
chill I was always like yeah I got weed
and I'm also drinking Mad Dogs so if you
eat weed let me know I was like so
disappointed in myself when he explained
to me I'm like what the [ __ ] was I doing
just playing basketball yeah you're a
good kid man I know but I was broke like
oh I was [ __ ] slipping I was still
broke too I liked weed more than money
man I would sell we just [ __ ] smoke
more weed yeah so you could buy more
weed the smell 100 the second I went how
much to make 150 I made it back I got
two Rams left boom those are mine like
it didn't matter man oh hold on let me
see the way you're rolling this that's
weird but I was like roll it like
that's definitely smart but it's like
problem is you always need to train [ __ ]
you know that's the issue oh okay so you
did the basically the dollar trick
except on a tray right now Dollar Tree
what's the dollar when you do the dollar
and you roll it over you never seen the
dollar how to roll it on a dollar I'll
show you that after this it's it's
clutch but we used to not be able to
roll in high school if you had a dollar
you you had a [ __ ] blunt you just you
hold the dollar in half put the blunt in
there and you use the dollar like this
and it molds the blunt just what you did
on this table same [ __ ] oh interesting
yeah because have you seen one of those
like automatic like blunt rollers that's
like this big they kind of work no they
work but it's also like you know I'm not
gonna keep this in the car I know I'm at
my home he's like don't hold on can I
plug my machine in so I don't have to
roll my blood yeah it's not uh well I
need to just pre-roll them before you
like to go somewhere right on the go and
I always run out of joints everywhere
I'm at I'd always end up having a Roma
weed
because I feel like I'm not saying where
the car's moving but I feel like the car
is my my most favorite place in the
world to smoke weed oh no I I do I don't
that's why I don't like rubies no more
it's the best like anywhere it's like we
have to drive I don't want to [ __ ]
ever Uber no unless I did the other day
and it was tragic they never let you
smoke weed in the car because it's not
your car I tried you guys every Uber in
[ __ ] event in New York like you can't
get a guy but you can't I'm like [ __ ]
now some of them do some of the Uber
like but you have to get a black though
if you don't get an Uber blocks it's all
over blacks oh then dude some of them do
something yeah really yeah that's why
let's get it Uber black and then message
them can I pay a cleaning fee to smoke
in your car I ask somebody can we pay
your smoking fee usually it'll be like
you know a couple hundred to do that
yeah but no never
because it's really like I hear the
stories and the myths of all my homies
yeah right my Ubers don't like me or
something but then all the private
drivers that like we've gone before they
always like already know that people are
probably gonna be smoking and they even
have ashtrays in the car for a lot of
them in New York none of them want to
smoke damn we even asked them you know
if we pay you like the extra [ __ ] two
hours can we no nothing
New York's not the same I guess I don't
know they were not down with us yeah I
guess it also was California yeah out
here is different but I know I've always
had my car here so I'm never getting a
[ __ ] Uber here unless I'm getting
[ __ ] drunk somewhere but rare
um okay sorry fan question real quick
let's get into this real fast before we
even do it
was it Mac Yahoo just said not even
questions thank you for all yeah overall
thank you for the years of content
that's all they wanted us most of them
wanted to say oh I appreciate it yeah a
lot of them are like I've been watching
so I was a kid thank you for the content
of course all right so that's the first
thing I want to say that most of the
fans
put in the [ __ ] question it wasn't
even a question like just say thank you
thank you all for watching it for real
that's I wouldn't let you know I'd [ __ ]
if they were watching if they weren't
watching that [ __ ] so when you meet a
fan in the public are you the people are
you stopping and taking pictures thank
you I don't I'm trying to remember a
time where I have it to be honest I
don't I can't because then we'll talk
about it later I'm like God I wish I
would have stopped
now I'm really trying to remember like
there was
I've definitely put myself in situations
like if I see like hella [ __ ]
like swarming someone like from Faith
like yeah I'm not going that way I've
done that like you know what I mean like
sometimes I've done that but like I'm
not ready for that right now but I've
never liked someone to be like no no
like that's just that's just me like I'm
crazy I feel bad like I don't know I was
just so mean to do that even if I'm in
like a restaurant like okay can I just
do it really quick please like because
I've got to go or if sometimes like
we're trying to get somewhere in certain
events like the security doesn't let you
that's different yeah that's me
personally I've never said no no yeah no
I don't care how many times you got off
from my [ __ ] restaurant I'm from like
some something bro there's like these
weird because face has gotten so big now
that there's these random weird like
they know what phase is but I don't know
anybody who's in phase and they just
want to take a picture with you because
like but they don't know anything about
you or face and they're saying it kind
of like yeah I don't know I just some of
those like I don't even call them fans
because they obviously don't know any
any of us like that but it says they
just come across weird to me because
like I don't know sometimes get that
there's there's always I've had a couple
days I don't know who you are but I see
people taking pictures with you
all right have a great have a great day
get the [ __ ] wrong with you I've had
that before and I've never felt more
like
you watch Space Jam yeah the new one no
the first one remember when he's like
you're gonna play one-on-one all day and
sign off forever forever that's how I
feel when like I don't know why I feel
like a [ __ ] boy whatever the [ __ ]
wrong with this like I feel like a thing
over here they want some likes off here
yeah
no but I just wanted to know because
it's like the
you said you watched you were watching
hex and then now you're in it and then
now you started making some money then
you then you're taking pictures with
people and it's almost to the point
where the first time you took a picture
with somebody and that made their
[ __ ] day and you can see it
isn't it it's a whole different thing in
your life like you could be 70 right now
and you're still gonna have a cult
following people like yo that's my
[ __ ] because me Adam Sandler
that's me like I love that fool so much
so there's there's people out there that
love you like they lose and I get that
and that's what a lot of people try to
tell me even like when they're older
like I haven't watched in a long time
but this is different because like and I
get it because they're my Jeff Hardy oh
there it is you know what I mean it's
like the way that like there's just
someone like you know I don't give a
[ __ ] about what he does but like like I
just you know what I mean like that's
probably the only and Morgan Freeman
because I want to hear him talk but Jeff
Hardy's the only person and that's like
even Eminem I [ __ ] him I'd just be
like oh cool Eminem but like dude Jeff
what
so that's your guy almost paralyzed
myself when I was 12. do me too I do the
Swanton Bomb by myself landing on my top
of my head couldn't move oh [ __ ] I cried
and then I moved my legs I was like oh
I'm okay I was a little kid what'd you
do I Swanton like you know those like CD
holders that like you they carry hella
CDs but it was like I don't know in what
world why I wanted to choose like a
stuffed animal why I said let me try to
put myself through pain but I did and
that [ __ ] on it yeah I thought that was
mine
like the ones that are like that big and
they hold like 50 CDs yeah when you take
off the CDs and this is kind of like are
you watching ecw2 or something oh so you
were there I want a Dudley boys my [ __ ]
okay and also I remember because like um
well I went to a couple shows when I was
a kid and I think at either Smackdown or
Raw they actually like filmed ECW at one
of them oh it wasn't its own live show
they do as like a pre-show because
they're still like small I remember like
yeah
yeah
ECW I don't even remember because I was
kind of far well I ever really remember
from that specific one with some kids
screaming about Hornswoggle the whole
time he's like heart swaggle behind you
behind you and we're so far away like
what are you screaming for kids I could
hear you you cannot [ __ ] hear you
he's screaming I'll never forget it that
kid's out there right now like [ __ ] he
bothered the [ __ ] out of me back then I
was like
dude so Jeff Hardy's here at okay I love
that dude as a kid all I cared about was
wrestling I made it up Chad my friend
Chad Holland walked into sixth grade ago
it's a nice WrestleMania shirt you got
on we were best [ __ ] friends right
didn't matter it didn't matter what else
we were like like you like wrestling to
we're homies now dude yeah I got
suspended from sixth grade for Stone
Cold stuttering a bunch of people with
Chad one kid told I found out senior
year who the [ __ ] is snitched on who
snitched on us six years later and then
you still considered him too no it's
this guy's sister she saw it from the
parking lot when she was picking them up
I thought we were picking on him did she
get stone cold centered or no no I found
out in 12th grade this was 10 years old
she's very Thirty but nah dude um
wrestling was my [ __ ] Jeff Hardy Matt
Hardy it couldn't have been cooler I
never was gonna wear fish in that shirts
but I thought they were the coolest for
wearing the [ __ ] they wore like I'm so
happy that's who you love because I [ __ ]
yeah like Jeff Hardy by far John Cena
was cool it was past my era but oh yeah
really yeah wait Jeff Hardy's still in
jail John Cena wasn't I stopped watching
wrestling pre-weed 12. I was wrong Jeff
Hardy was in the WWF when you were
watching yeah what Jeff Hardy I didn't
know that I didn't know he was like that
and from that long ago Jeff Hardy
probably started wrestling 2 000. so
even like when like everyone's in the
wrong Rock everyone I didn't know that
oh was he the same Vibe though exactly
same thing colored hair doing everything
he was they were the alternative new
group back when uh Edge the wrestler was
there
um like Batista and everything that was
I never even really nah I just seen him
from movies and knew he was a wrestler I
never saw John Cena like The Rock was
the good guy when I left that's the
thing I watched WWF as it transitioned
in the E so I actually saw the Rockets
as soon as that happened I was done yeah
because that's the year I started so
weird oh okay that's it but it didn't
get as PG till after because they didn't
switch the name to gut PG they switched
the name because I think the World
Wildlife Foundation sued their ass
um
[Music]
so they have to become entertainment
instead but they weren't then go full PG
yet I remember when they went PG I
stopped watching too but also because
Jeff Hardy like he had a thing with CM
Punk and then like he like I don't know
who that was he went to the UFC though
and got his ass beat you didn't hear
about that see him oh that's the same
person yeah CM Punk you're correct about
the wildlife sir yeah you're correct oh
2002 2002
that's the year I started smoking weed
20 years just like you said yeah 20
years yes your anniversary that's crazy
yeah dude uh
[ __ ] I missed that guy yeah no he was a
legend but that's what happened he like
had a thing with like CM Punk it was
like a Hell in the Cell and then like
loser like the loser of that or actually
it was a cage match I think whatever but
like loser had to like not be in the WWE
anymore and then like he lost on some
[ __ ] dude so you were done you're a
die-hard then yeah it wasn't even rigged
when I used to watch it back then it was
real back then
no it's Vegas okay I remember I wanted
to beat my sisters she's like it's fake
I'm like no the [ __ ] it's not my sister
she said [ __ ] to me too I'm like it's
not fake looking and bleeding Thomas
those are packets like those are now
packets you could see the cut you can
never see the cut I would always
convince myself that's the cut he's
bleeding he's I know he's bleeding I
don't know why I wanted to believe that
lie so bad me too but when the rock or
the fan is like everything WWE is real
it is it was real but then people's
elbow came out it wasn't real no more he
took 48 seconds of showboating and then
elbow dropped you that's when I knew it
was like it's over I say it's not
freaking real no more because he I mean
like as a kid
Israel it's not I saw I was smoking a
joint one time in Hollywood and X-Pac
sat next to me at a table do you
remember x-pocket General age I know
Triple H oh wait you're not talking
about like HBK like Shawn Michaels right
no no no I mean Heartbreak Kid and all
those yeah I know what you know you know
Shawn Michaels right yeah of course oh
okay so damn you remember Xbox and China
you know you know China like the girl
right yeah okay Xbox was the little dude
with the long black hair it's kind of
dead on my trip yeah she's gone which is
crazy yeah yeah she's been definitely
man I don't know I don't remember I
remember she died sad I don't damn Marty
with the power of the internet I would
find out
um all right sorry off traffic let's get
it let's get into this question real
quick because we never [ __ ] did Marty
can we get into the fan question that we
never got into
uh yeah I said before we start let me
ask you something you take pictures with
people that then it's crazy we get off
topic that's my life bro I mean we are
smoking weed during the podcast it'll
happen right so here we go it's from Jay
I can't say your name doozy man when you
first started YouTube what was the
biggest lesson you learned as a YouTuber
making content getting paid what would
you do different if you got to stay
strong during the lows September and
January they're the worst months like
even like CPM wise and like this people
go back to school and [ __ ] like I don't
know it's like post holiday would always
be like the worst and like even as
sometimes you just gotta get used to
like bad months and not like let it get
to your head because like I can see how
people can let numbers get their head
crazy it's like a weird other type of
drug seriously like that was like before
we like that was my drug social blade
dude that was my [ __ ] drug he showed
me socially recently stats all dead live
on that [ __ ] so like it's just a
different type of drug you know what I
mean but it's like you got to learn to
kind of just like I don't know
disassociate a little bit with like look
at it you know keep track like this is
like but also it's like hard to say that
because sometimes you really do excel
the most when you're like a numbers
freak and you too obsessive sure so it's
like I don't know as long as it doesn't
like tax you too much mentally
do handle whatever like your mind can
handle you know I mean like if your mind
like if you really stress out about
numbers and maybe don't as much but like
if you can handle it and do it you know
what I mean I feel you do because like I
said I wasn't shadow man I'm in shadow
man since 2019 they kicked me off the
program so that must be getting annoying
always like getting to this follow
amount then I drop and then starting
over then getting like a tenth of the
engagement or under the engagement
because you're on a new account so it's
like it feels yeah it gets to your head
I get it but forget me and then I pay
for everything out of pocket never got
paid from YouTube so it's even worse on
my how much I spend and it's Shadow band
and then we saw it and they're running
ads on still and they're still running
ads on my [ __ ] never got paid like I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill someone that's how I
felt but like you said you have to stay
Stronger Yeah that's what I preach like
there's years where I'm like is this
gonna work the cool and bad part about
YouTube is like you're never you're only
as big as your next video or your last
video yeah so it's like it always
matters it's like if it flops who cares
make the next one that one could pop and
it's like then it doesn't even matter
that that last one flopped because the
next one popped and then you play off
momentum with that one so it's like yep
I don't know you just gotta like I think
it's with everything in entertainment
it's only as good as what people can
remember because could be the biggest
artist ever on earth like dude we
haven't seen an artist like this so they
get to drop a [ __ ] Banger that
everyone starts listening to again and
they get yeah or three years later you
go damn where they at man I haven't
heard from them in a while you how many
times you do you hear a song go I forgot
about this we'll turn it up yeah it kind
of makes me sure oh that's [ __ ] up man
but you're only as good as your last
[ __ ] it's true yeah it really is a
little bit different with like movies I
feel like because like I don't know
they're more like Timeless in a way like
good movies like a great actor in a good
movie like it doesn't like Jim Carrey
you don't even need to be doing [ __ ]
yeah you know what I mean right off in
the Sun
forever it's like with YouTube you're
not really watching videos like that old
you know I mean the bulk of people are
watching the new content always you're
not watching the old [ __ ] but with
movies you're always going back and
watching the whole [ __ ] half the movies
I watch every minute are older they're
not even like not old old but like you
know 2010 to 15 and 16 like not always
the newest newest [ __ ] because I feel
like new movies suck now yeah [ __ ] yeah
unless it's like a marvelous are you a
movie person are you into this or is
this something like yeah I'll watch a
new one depends there's levels to that
right okay so that's what you said then
that means yes do you like movies and
you're not gonna sit and just watch the
[ __ ] there's so many Banger movies
you're gonna list though like you said
Pulp Fiction earlier haven't seen it a
lot of the that's three hours right two
and a half 240. it's pushing three yes I
should stay away from the threes yeah oh
yeah I always think of the longer ones
as this is someone's life work I gotta
see this [ __ ] like I saw a headline
recently that's gonna like that means
I'm not watching Avatar too three and a
half hours I'm pretty sure that's too
much no sir not me
[ __ ] no you can't smoke in a movie
theater for three and a half hours you
got me [ __ ] up that's true that's true
bootleg you if you gotta wait a minute
till it's blue like you gotta wait till
it's on streaming services and for
Avatar Two it's gonna be at least three
months before it's on like iTunes and
you're like I don't know and then it
gets ripped off in HD because they keep
that file I'm like
I've been waiting so if I could like to
me Avatar is damn near one of the best
like last movies you know like but you
know it was cool it like it had no like
cultural impact really like I've never
seen Avatar meme or a reference sure or
anything well honestly it's like the
most cool movie of all time is it yes
yes James Cameron broke his own record
from Titanic I gotta be honest bro it's
cool
it's cool it's FernGully live action
without tractors
FernGully is an old ass Disney movie
about that but you know he has like five
coming out right five like two three
four and five of Avatar yeah I'm [ __ ]
done afterwards pretty sure they're
dropping every two years after this one
already because we had like a stun actor
Cumberland like 2020 to help with like
some shoot we were doing and he's like
the stunt man for avatars and like he
works with James Cameron and [ __ ] and he
was telling us that like four and five
were like the best rated movies ever
seen in his [ __ ] life but they're
already filming for so I think they've
already filmed two and three or
something like I don't care enough I
don't think anybody gives a [ __ ] enough
avatars I think so
I had no idea people that was a most
selling movie ever you ever heard of
that movie that says like you're not
going to see this movie and like the
drop day is like
yeah it's in 100 years from I forget
what John Malkovich yeah I don't even
know who that is but it's the active
concept
you know the whole Blockbuster movie it
comes out in
2021 it comes out in like 94 more years
so it's like in the beginnings like
every single person that's working on
this film is now dead every single thing
you're gonna see is something from the
past every single thing you're gonna see
is this this and it doesn't come out for
another like 90 years damn [ __ ]
awesome I think it's such a cool concept
the best concept ever it's a time
capsule of what you think might be this
[ __ ] exactly it's a movie time I love
that man [ __ ] awesome favorite three
movies ever go
um law-abiding citizen get out oh I've
just had so I've run that movie way too
many times and I'm on the fence between
like Lion King and Shrek 2 but I'm gonna
have to go
but it's like for different moments in
my life too but Shrek 2 is like Elite
dude
I love Shrek too crazy it's so important
dude you're talking about the original
ranking I might have to kick get out
honestly I didn't put it first one right
not the newish of course not okay the
first the new one's so cute though new
one's great I thought the new one was
great never gonna beat the old one those
is a mess you know what's annoying so
much about the new one like they swapped
out some words that they could have just
kept normal
yeah and even in the song like when
they're saying like the what it takes to
be king or whatever like they [ __ ]
that up too like I don't know it's like
Aladdin they did the same thing they
changed that little [ __ ] a little bit
they changed the Latin slightly too
bothered me no I I get what you're
saying I love that stuff to throw in
this Pumbaa it matched amazing matched
[ __ ] amazing could have got a better
person to play that okay voice yeah that
was a good one dude no um that was a
very odd for uh that was awesome it was
well thought out he knew he knew he
really knew Law Abiding Citizen who's in
that movie Gerard Butler Jamie Foxx
never seen that incredible movie go
watch it tonight really let's watch the
time I will please if it's that good
cheerful favorite movie yeah I get
excited time I watch it it's [ __ ]
sick
I hope I haven't seen it because if I
start watching oh I have seen this movie
because I have a photographic memory I
remember almost everything Jamie Jim
Jamie Foxx is like you would remember
him by face if he was in a movie like
you know yeah okay so he's in it he's
like the detective like I think he's a
Fed like a guy agent Gerard Butler's
planting bombs
is that this movie a little bit
I feel like I would he goes to prison
Gerard Butler's in prison oh yo that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] hard as [ __ ] right he
puts the machine guns in the [ __ ]
control yeah oh that movie's tight as
hell I have seen that movie yeah that's
a good I was gonna like spoil the whole
thing but it's okay if you haven't
watched it you can watch it yeah I have
seen that it's been a few memories off
the chain I just remember of him in
cuffs and he's like he killed fools
without even being exactly
yeah that's like always he's like a
Spartan now he played the same character
from 300 but like now as a Monster yeah
it's a good movie all right that's a
good [ __ ] movie never mind yeah no I
love it all right that's a good pick I
do remember that movie where do you
stand on Forrest Gump there you go one
of those I've never seen I felt like it
I knew it a lot of those movies like I
just never seen you could probably name
some bangers that have this news yeah
I feel like when it comes to movies and
monumental points of human history and
screw and filming and dialogue people
doing Shakespeare for hundreds of years
in theater to get a movie that [ __ ]
good down and out it's Forrest Gump
really [ __ ] amazing isn't it just
like him reflecting on himself when he's
like I guess I'll [ __ ] I don't know not
even one bit then he starts running and
[ __ ] nope that's the P that's the pop
culture [ __ ] they took from it so they
can do costumes about it I was laughing
about the running not even a little bit
that [ __ ] didn't come until like [ __ ]
70 of the movie oh damn he's a mentally
handicapped dude that's basically they
take them mentally you say mentally
handico oh yeah you need to watch it he
takes him through history he's in every
part of American History he's physically
handicapped no he's fast as [ __ ]
oh as a kid yeah you gotta wait I don't
want to [ __ ] you up you got to watch it
it's one of those it's one of those
movies that's like whoever put this [ __ ]
together [ __ ] go to there or like
Castaway it's not the movie called
Castle is great but he's not like 70
[ __ ] words there's a good movie just
because it's like he's on an island with
a volleyball or something right yeah but
you gotta think of the thing of like yo
you held and carried a movie with no
words you're a good [ __ ] actor bro oh
he didn't talk he only said a few words
the whole movie so what the [ __ ] the
movie about about him stuck on an island
it's great
really oh it's good because if you the
way I look at it at movies is like I'm a
big movie person it's like no that actor
I forgot of a snack but are you sure
it's actually a good movie because you
know how your standards change as things
come out right so it's like well it's
good back then isn't good today and so
that's true you confuse Nostalgia with
actually go that's true like craft
dinner is it actually good or is it
nostalgic we just love it because it's
nostalgic no it just had a commercial on
it oh we got hooked like oh crash
macaroni and cheese and that was it like
yo mom can I get some macaroni you know
what I mean but it's marketing as for
kids it's like someone trying it in
their 30s who's never tried it before
might not think it's good but like
someone who's eating it their whole life
loves it because it's a Nostalgia for
sure you know what I mean that's with
everything though there's a lot of like
Lunchables dude most people are garbage
but they were bomb when I was a kid I'll
still eat them
slimy though yeah they are it makes me
feel like what power plant made yeah
weirdly slimy you just have to ignore it
with the crackers
[ __ ] nah dude you gotta watch it man if
you if there's anything you take away
watch at least for a good movie over
Pulp Fiction for me always but Pulp
Fiction is that action I don't want to
watch any of his movies no and he got a
foot fetish Quentin Tarantino yeah oh
it's not in this one it starts to Kill
Bill Moore oh no it is not Pulp Fiction
look at any of his movies there's a lot
of good movies
Pulp Fiction uh wrote Reservoir Dogs
True Romance hero with all the Kill
Bills uh Django I tried the ones but I
fell asleep like four times great same
[ __ ] so hard to walk Batman was okay
it's like make it a little bit brighter
thank you he basically did this I'm
gonna [ __ ] save the [ __ ] City it
was emo Batman and I'm trying to push it
away so it doesn't happen and it was
okay it was all right I know Eric's a
[ __ ] bad man fanatic and I was
talking to him about Batman I'm like
that's your favorite movie
Batman The Dark Knight no that's not
true he's amazing no it's a great movie
I just don't think superhero movies I
can ever be like my favorite if you ask
me top five Dark Knight would have been
in that no you know how many people
agreed with Eric on them I guess my
favorite move all time and Lion King and
get out and and Lion King and what's up
are you sure those aren't Nostalgia no
it's not because I literally watched it
like three days ago okay can I just
watch foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's sad no it's disappointing
it's the worst movie I've ever seen in
my life I could imagine probably though
what's the worst movie you ever seen in
your life other than Halloween ends um
[ __ ] that's the thing I just forget
about it because it's so bad I remember
one because it was so bad where I gotta
tell everybody I saw almost 10. it's
called Mexican blow
it's in Spanish so bad
it's about a Mexican Indian Aztec that
discovers the city it's 10 feet from his
village you just discovered it but he's
got magic powers and the cartel takes
him over and uses power for drug dealing
worst movie I ever watched my life well
already made a mistake as a kid I wanted
I thought have you heard of the movie
Devil's where Devil Wears products I've
recently watched it for the first time I
thought it was a horror movie when I was
a kid
I went to it I'm sitting there for 30
minutes
oh my kids [ __ ] is working out like
Saint Laurent or the [ __ ] dude what the
[ __ ] is scary about this where is the
devil like dog
I'm sorry
me and my brother we ended up just
leaving went on some random some random
like kids movie I don't even know
when's it gonna get scary no it's about
designer and a girl getting a job as a
designer brand yeah it's a checkbook
foreign
that's funny to me out of the way
um that's a Michaels do you watch the
office that's a Michael Scott no I
missed out on the office then when I
tried to watch it I'm like lame really
yeah maybe that sucks maybe that's not
that good either oh no I started
watching it there's no way it's not a
banger for me it's uh it's just I just
like film [ __ ] so it's like oh around
season three he really builds his own
that's right that's not filmed like a
show though I love it it's like it's
original like it broke that yeah it's
like fourth wall yeah I'm looking at the
camera and [ __ ] that's what split that's
what people are anyone that's over 15
and under 50 right now that's the like
the brain wave we're all on I feel like
our attention spans are a little less
than everyone else's are you a Breaking
Bad kind of guy it was cool I liked it
great movie I mean great show that's
great show it's cool I know I don't know
that's his favorite [ __ ] it's not an
acceptable answer right at least it was
good it's cool yeah it was great good
all right that's crazy though to me it's
like number two of all time if you want
to talk about evolution of a character
you go from you never watch them in the
middle but I'm I understand that's not
going to middle too I know I'm saying to
see how go into that I was just watching
the show come out like I'm hyped
no I'm saying like seeing like that's
the funniest dad ever on sitcoms to be
in the scariest dad and Eddie sitcom for
actors for me and my [ __ ] like watching
him play that character was [ __ ]
awesome he was such a bad guy but you
stole a rooting for him of course but at
the end you're like it's okay you died
you're bad I know but I'm sad yeah
exactly no it was a great show I watched
it as it was coming out even the movie
they followed up with what it was cool
it was cool and I didn't watch Better
Call Saul but everyone said I never
watched it they haven't done anything to
like [ __ ] with it you know like shows
will [ __ ] with their [ __ ] yeah like
they'll drop a season for no reason like
Dexter oh I know I don't watch that [ __ ]
I was already mad at the ending of
season eight and then I said all right
let's drop he's gonna make even more mad
like [ __ ] you yeah I was on money
grabbed I mean like how dare you come
back for this one season with this half
ass he watched that [ __ ] too I watched
the intro and it grossed me out so I
never watched the show The Cutting and
him eating up closer I don't want to see
that [ __ ] he doesn't do it that often it
was just I was only one they only like
painted in the beginning just so you get
the idea then they don't really like
even the kills get they you know like
show it as much they just like it was
kind of watered down I only watched one
episode and that was the only one I ever
got and he was he stabbed the first
giant dude in the neck and the guy
started fighting him that he was
supposed to kill and I'm like you're
murdering people I don't want to watch
this nasty [ __ ] little Chino the big
[ __ ] dude he stabbed his ass you know
that's the only episode
the only one I've ever seen dude yeah
and that made me go I'm good I don't
like seeing people get cut it grosses me
the [ __ ] out but it's fake blood still
bad it's because they have the little
squeezy thing on the other side of the
blade it's actually watch like how they
do it does it help me it's this little
squeeze ketchup dude
I need like Halloween movies can't like
even try like I watched terrifier too
because everyone's like what's so gross
dude it's a movie like it's not real no
I know nothing's real no I don't know
how to explain it but I always every
time I watch a movie I can just see it
as fake it's like I know there's a
cameraman
that's why Shrek 2 is Elite that would
suck because there's no cameraman I
would hate that that's a great point
about animated movies I've thought that
before too I'm I make videos and [ __ ]
I'm always looking at how do you get
that shot
great movie that's how I think I think
like building like building like that
actor had to do that what was he
thinking right before that scene because
that [ __ ] [ __ ] his pants and
that's like you know they're like damn
this [ __ ] this movie's crazy but no I
can't watch Gore [ __ ] dude yeah I don't
know why it's like a it's like a vibe
that comes in my living room like why do
I want this evil [ __ ] around me like it
gives me that feeling of like walking at
night wearing blue in the wrong part of
town like [ __ ] [ __ ] and I gotta run or
something it's like dudes the same fear
of like nah it's that fight or flight
feeling my chest I start getting like
damn put on [ __ ] Seinfeld [ __ ] this
I've never seen that either oh [ __ ]
um you should watch it I mean I think
I've seen a couple episodes yeah it's
always a lot of people like yo I've seen
this and this but you didn't watch the
bass you had to watch them they did
everything for that show too like he
like made the bulk of the money off the
show because Larry David and Jerry
Seinfeld you know you ever seen Kirby
enthusiasm no I've heard of it but I
thought Seinfeld did somewhere he like
owned the most because he like did
everything kind of the way Seth
MacFarlane does with Family Guy where he
does like all the voices Larry David
voices is the writer with Jerry Seinfeld
they both co-write and Co okay yeah but
that's something they like write their
own show do they like interact and
produce it too um not direct and not
directors okay I thought they did
everything I feel like when people start
getting money like season six you'll
start seeing produced by and the actor
because like yo no it's my show I'm
produced I'm making the money but the
first one's always like NBC knew this
but now Seinfeld was it was more of
pre-internet
so it was like the water cooler talk it
was like the only big funny show for New
Yorkers like yo you see Seinfeld and it
just got bigger than life I think yeah
yeah you're from New York no from here
oh I I grew up watching everything with
my grandma and grandpa so I was watching
that [ __ ] at like four dying laughing at
these [ __ ] so I've been
watching since I was a kid yeah but I
found a lion king too [ __ ] I watched all
that [ __ ] but I've been watching
my mom was a shitty mom when I was a kid
so she let me watch the real bad [ __ ] as
a kid so that's why I think my brain's
different so I've been watching all the
pulp fictions when it came out I
shouldn't have been watching that [ __ ]
it's not meant to be first you're a
fresh prince guy
okay cool
I'm just not a Frasier guy
[ __ ] hate Frasier I don't know
anybody that's ever watched it when I
like it he's the only one from the 90s
that you really have like [ __ ] hate
for Kelsey Grammar and Frasier [ __ ]
I don't know real quick you guys ready
ready let's do one more fan question
before we add here because we still
haven't done that [ __ ] yo we've been
talking and ranting again and what
happened we started talking about one
thing and it takes like 40 minutes to
answer a fan question it does dude it
always happens with this especially when
we get lost in conversation like this
but it's not a big deal I'm down with it
um all right here we go that means
they're good questions there are they're
good before actually this was a question
I was gonna ask too you say you only do
micro dosing on mushrooms no I don't
really do it that was like a while ago
oh okay when you did do it yeah you said
it made you feel different like you like
the micro dozen I love it but then I got
sick from doing it too much because I
was doing it every day and my micro
doses are hell no there weren't micro
doses dude they were taking shrooms two
grams yeah at least like an eighth two
months oh damn yeah but it didn't hit me
like that so it's micro dose dude yeah
you met the tolerance you built it up
yeah and then you're eating all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] because it's growing [ __ ]
dude the mushrooms are going to [ __ ] oh
you're poisoning yourself every day
weirdest type of sick I don't even know
it was like I don't know it was just and
it made me like all [ __ ] up I haven't
done it since I didn't think I've done
shrooms since no what was the biggest
though she ever took on mushrooms I
don't know probably like a half ounce oh
[ __ ] but it like wasn't like that insane
I've only done eight grams I don't know
it's all that pain you guys haven't
tried the right shroom
penis Albano like white and blue thing
that's what I took the other day
penis envies and albinos oh yeah this is
called actually is it penis envy it's
the same one right yeah same thing yeah
that was the question from that guy Pete
hard again once again he's always
getting good questions and we already
asked people it's like the fifth
question we've got of him but he wanted
to ask what's the most you ever taken I
have found yeah you're a [ __ ] monster
I could never do that insane I feel like
I remember once I don't also it's always
so different sometimes it'll take I
remember eating these chocolate bars and
I ate like two of them and I was Cooling
and then I took a small piece from the
third one and then randomly dog like I
just destroyed me dog like I don't know
I just [ __ ] would not be able to walk
like on [ __ ] mushrooms because I've
done that before like I've been so
[ __ ] up where I can't even move you
ever done that I mean just during dude I
just came out of a wheelchair again
yeah
he knew that hey man it was a good
question then but not mushrooms you're
actually gonna pause so much but what
happened Jesus I was like what are you
looking at he's just it's funny you say
that though because before that that's
also why like I had some I have like
some nerve damage that CRPS it's all
[ __ ] up so I'm like kind of tripping
on microdose while I'm doing like
streams and [ __ ] but after that sickness
from shrooms like back in the day Market
ocean I got something called like
restless leg syndrome I don't know if
you know what that is but like yeah it
was weird it can't sleep weird as [ __ ]
one I couldn't sit down like I had to
walk to the hospital dad I couldn't sit
in an Uber for five minutes because it
was like I had to just walk and it was
for 48 hours straight I could not sit
down dude at all it was like as if I sat
down and feel like electricity is
building and it was like hurt crazy oh
like the static feeling yeah like button
and like unbelievable sleep kind of
thing but like an unbelievable amount
like you cannot sit like it was crazy
I've I've never I remember I got that
after but it was weird because I got it
from a cough
like I got a cough from that sickness
and I was coughing so hard that I felt
something pull like down here and then I
was weird oh no yeah I came from like a
cough
that's what it felt like at least
because I started coughing and then I
and then
I just couldn't I've coughed so hard I
[ __ ] in my I hurt my back put off bong
ribs like damn I pulled a muscle in my
back I'm coughing yeah but damn restless
leg no I've experienced it but not
non-stop yeah
ah never sounds horrible yeah once again
that's pretty ass yeah that was that was
a pretty wild question but what I meant
was have you ever been stuck so hard on
mushrooms you can't [ __ ] move or do
anything I have and it was right there
two weeks ago on the show that's what I
was gonna say like I have and it was
over there because dude if you're taking
a half ounce I don't understand how you
can function
because I've done the eight I know
because people told me you took eight
grams of mushrooms are you [ __ ]
stupid like I'm sorry but you took a
half I can never even to like literally
everything I've ever tried tolerance
through the roof the only thing that my
tolerance will never go up on is Edibles
for some reason oh [ __ ] I don't know
what it is but everything else like I'm
fine but Edibles man really like if you
give me like I remember I don't think
they exist anymore but cushy punches
like a hundred yeah they're still there
oh I don't think you do anymore let me
[ __ ] still [ __ ] on me yeah there's no
way just those yeah oh my God and like
you know Ben Baller is like yeah he used
to have like this like THC lean but he
used to put like a thousand milligrams
in that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that's what's in
there in that box I got right there is
it like OD though is it like we used to
put it I wouldn't drink it all wait
because I think the maximum is like 300
this is three this is only 200
milligrams yeah you should put it like
over a thousand and he's like I'm just
gonna do it till they stop me yeah
[ __ ] awesome yeah so so wait
sorry I keep trying to think back on
like
when you take a half ounce are you
eating a half ounce of just straight
mushrooms yeah you're not mixing it with
nothing no I'm just like what I would
drink it at that time even though I
don't drink alcohol at all about
drinking a white claws dude or something
really bitter
because they taste gross like it's been
hanging out for YouTube
no no he wasn't there for anything oh so
usually but he can't post Wheels
mushrooms yeah I was like stop please
stop right now holy [ __ ] that sounds
like a beach day
and tolerance is high man yeah they hit
but it wasn't like that crazy like when
I took like four tabs to ask that was
crazy oh you like drugs yeah that's
tough that's tight no psychedelics man
you thugs are cool but that's what I
mean but I also I don't feel like you
should do them that often I feel like
you just never mess it for people that
like want to do them like nervous dude
every now and then I'm so nervous yeah
neither of us
after the last episode I'm not scared I
just can't do them and function on the
show I can't do it no more it was two
it's too intense huh because you know
I'm having a conversation with myself
here while trying to have a conversation
with a guest and then remember hey man
you're on camera like that's why I said
she's tripping because you're like to
anybody who's watching like what the
[ __ ] going on with that guy yep you're
really tripping
because you feel like you move
to wherever that thought is like imagine
like your entire brain like your
thoughts are all scattered across but
like when you move it's like you [ __ ]
get like sucked back and you're seeing
pulled to that thought in a way like I
don't know it's trippy as [ __ ] acid's
more mental seems more emotional streams
play off your emotions more and then
brings those kind of to life and then
like acids like straight mental you're
in your brain digging through [ __ ] right
at least in your files and [ __ ] well
like that it's like this it takes over
your emotions in a sense that like it's
just that's the main thing that you
notice as the differentiator like
you get more emotional on shrooms but
when you're on acid it's more just like
like I don't know like technical more
like in your thought like I don't know
like it's less emotional like I was
never crying a [ __ ] acid but some
shrooms a lot of streams they make you
like crying [ __ ] yeah and emotional what
the [ __ ] I'm never I'm just nervous for
acid but that sounds [ __ ] like a good
way to say it like this is accessing
files yeah it's just clearing out your
emotions yeah yeah that's a good one to
see what your brain can do like let's
soup this up a little bit and see what
it can do because you're talking about
neurologic what do you say foreign I
never thought about it like that but
there's been times where I come off my
my trip and go did something change is
my brain Clear I felt like that but it
goes away three days later like the
world comes back you know what I mean
yeah when you're tripping so hard like
my name you state your name 30 times but
why is that my name I've done that so
many that's like anything you say a word
30 times why is it that word mushrooms
it's like it's so much more intense I'm
like my face that's what people see
that's my face all right all right cool
that's how it's it's weird it's like you
start to sink like
you see everything's so different
everything is so different like I can
just like you said the the movement that
it's called because some people are very
like narrow-minded so they don't gain
much perspective so for them it can help
them like open up a little bit you know
yeah dude my mom's really taking
mushrooms like a year straight now she's
on it dude because she's tried and was
like oh I can think a little better or
oh this helps me for the anxiety of this
and that it's it's just something that's
going to be used I think like weed soon
yeah I think that a lot of people end up
taking it and they like I feel like
become a lot more understanding after
because they gain more perspective to a
lot more things than it just generally
makes them a more understanding person
that sounds weird but I still think like
Mike Tyson's came out and said that [ __ ]
but I personally feel the same way
because it makes me understand more than
you become more understanding and then
everything everyone does makes sense so
you're more understanding towards
someone like empathetic because you
understand like whatever they did they
did it for some reason yeah you know
what I mean no even if it only makes
sense in their head it doesn't make
sense to me like
now the more understanding you become
the more you can understand not take it
personally as to like they're not doing
that to me that's just kind of how they
are yeah it's like
totally I know yeah I feel like it's
like every six months someone should
just take some mushrooms and clear out
their head it's like a little it's like
a taking the it's a cleaning day spring
cleaning that's how I feel so for the
last time I just I didn't use it the
right way I usually get [ __ ] up that's
the thing and that's also why I feel
like like those type of drugs are like
they're not like legal and accessible
like that's because people can easily
misuse them and there's no like guide to
that for the most part right there's
like instructions yeah yeah that's true
that's true because I know I know people
right now like don't eat mushrooms you
never [ __ ] right there's like so many
people that you know that shouldn't have
like you're too high strong and you're
gonna [ __ ] jump off a building just
stay here like I feel like never in my
life tell her to [ __ ] try any of that
[ __ ] what does she do what do you mean
for Life what does she do for like her
living what does she do well she'd be
chilling dude she's just been chilling I
always ask the guests she like um like
she's been like a waitress before and
stuff but she like works at like
immigration like to help like refugees
and [ __ ] in the Canada oh nice yeah it
sounds like a government job it's a
government phone cool stay away from me
with that government phone
yeah I don't want to be near that thing
but yeah I always ask me like what was
the Chevy Woods what's your brother do I
actually [ __ ] makes videos or what do
you do I make music I always ask because
it's always funny like people always ask
me what is what is your family doing my
sister you know she [ __ ] makes
[ __ ] smells and perfumes she works at
this place so it's always I want to ask
like what is your sibling do yeah it's
always it's always weird to me because
you were you were 16 just make a video
making video game Clips 10 years later
you're like there's fans outside like
I'm gonna go sign some [ __ ] it's
different so it's like how does your
sister like take that was she super good
in school and you were the one [ __ ]
up yeah she was yeah she was definitely
better in school when I was one [ __ ]
up for sure it's always that way man
yeah I've never met a guest that says no
no we all did good or we were all
[ __ ] sucked it's never been I didn't
care about most of like what they were
teaching me I only like math well that
sounds like whatever but I only like
math that was it everything makes sense
yeah it makes sense everything else does
every time it makes sense like this is
what I was saying exactly geography like
I'm like an L for not caring as much
about that because like geography is
also consistent actually it's not that
because it's because it's changed it's
still smaller on this map yeah but still
for our lifetime it's gonna be the same
for the most part so still not the best
geographically but history it's all cap
what the [ __ ] am I gonna learn about
their [ __ ] story bro I know people
today they can't tell a story straight
when they try to tell a story from like
two weeks ago what's wrong don't tell me
the Civil War
s back then knew what the [ __ ] they were
talking about stop and they'd even like
my skin color you shouldn't say that
they didn't lose once
like some of it is true but it's like
the way that it's old cap like I don't
yeah no like you're saying like two
years ago this fool didn't even get a
story right you know how many times
that's happened right here like he told
me something different like bro I was
there or just how much people will tell
a story differently that you know 100
true and they're alive but to make
themselves see more just like whatever
whatever is insecurity whatever the [ __ ]
it may be give them
to write books that's when the world
that's what I'm saying yeah no I get it
so history it was never challenged them
because they're all dead and like no one
knows and it's like oh my God this is
like what the [ __ ] are we gonna say
that's not she's just like
you know that's
damned down the [ __ ] education system
right now they're all dead was it a lie
let's [ __ ] do math exactly though I
like it I like all right before we get
out of here can I actually do one actual
fan question and fully through it
because I know it hasn't got there yet
all right oh also one thing this is 30
million dollar face house what the [ __ ]
I mean we like rented it dude we didn't
buy it but it was awesome it's like it's
over you know no one lives there anymore
you're like from phase
so you guys all live together and just
did content yeah remember I I was while
you guys are having doing this like I
always think like people are the biggest
of their whole genre this is crazy and
you go ask a 60 year old mango what what
what's Call of Duty like it's crazy that
people can walk down the street have no
[ __ ] a lot of them know now because
they have like kids and [ __ ] yeah but
like parents a lot of them will know
because of their kids and stuff like
that for sure but you know like that
there's a part of the world that has no
idea what this game is but then you go
we have a 30 million dollar [ __ ]
house to make content for our fans yeah
so when you guys did that was it let's
go over the top just to go over the top
yeah even though I don't I didn't like
it as much like our best [ __ ] came out
of a 3 000 a month rented house in Long
Island like that was like the peak of
phase best part of phase it's like I
don't know me personally like where I'm
in life like living through in all those
houses like I don't know it's like even
harder to connect with the people you're
with when you're that spaced out and
everyone starts living their own life
when especially in like places like la
like in New York it was cool because
like the house was small so like we'd
always see each other and always do [ __ ]
together and that's where more content
happened because we were Rich around
each other and [ __ ] was happening but
then when everyone gets like kind of
split up in those big ass houses and
then their own rooms and [ __ ] like that
kind of lose that connection with each
other a little bit I get it's like the
band when they're starting down on the
bus on the on the van yeah it hits and
then they got their own sprinters they
all have their own [ __ ] tours exactly
just like I get it you lose the like
jackass One Versus Jack S3 and it's
different with us because it's like at
least with music they can come together
and make music they don't have to be
that close like that you know what I
mean they can just keep doing what the
[ __ ] they're doing but like with us like
it matters that like chemistry that
connection so it's like if you're losing
in A [ __ ] massive ass Mansion it's
like I don't know and you said people
are here for you not really for the
games as much anymore so what happens
when you kind of take out you be
camaraderie again yeah I get it I just I
haven't liked them to be honest it just
hasn't hit the same but I get it like
we're all just different places in life
that's why
I don't know I don't know if a house
with the same people will ever happen
again like that because it's like we're
also just too grown now dude we're like
pushing 30 like it was cool when we're
like younger and it felt like college
for us can't get away but then also it's
like dude I don't like living with dudes
they don't clean up after themselves so
I had room at once so I'm sure it's just
not the same when you're like yo I
cleaned it why is it dirty that's not me
and then you start feeling like I am not
a maid and I'm not also gonna live in
filth so I guess I'm a maid like that 30
million dollar house you're talking
about I couldn't go down to the kitchen
without shoes on because the floor is
always [ __ ] dirty and sticky dude
yeah gross yeah
yeah bro they're coming four times a
week it doesn't matter oh it's dirty as
they're cleaning like it's bad oh they
must have hated you guys like [ __ ] or go
back they actually like it was like
Elizabeth and they like loved us they
were especially like Banks and all them
because they've been like their clean
ladies forever for like five years and
like they love them oh then there's a
whole different [ __ ] story they must
love you guys like oh four times a week
they give us the most [ __ ] business
of anything for real though they've
gotten like amazing business like yeah
definitely have some phase and
especially banks in them so I had to ask
that because like I said once again in
not being in the Video Game World or
knowing or being on YouTube I was
already I was like what do you mean
because he brought it up how and then
you guys are what does that mean that
you guys are open on an open market what
does that mean because I was like public
like one of some things that publicly
traded company so your team like it's
like an NFL team at that point yeah you
could call like that okay so you guys
went public and basically let people
come in and take [ __ ] anything like buy
shares okay so you guys are still the
owners I'm like tripping on because I
know there's so much I don't know how to
say like when you especially even say
now people can do that like I don't know
like SEC dude oh yeah I'm so there's so
much yeah you guys have to be big on
everything I say that's fine that's fine
so basically it's because I don't know
what I'm saying is like now you guys can
cash out on making video or playing
video games basically sure yeah I think
it's great because Eric told me a little
bit ago
stop what the [ __ ] are you saying to me
because you told me like a year ago I
was like phase I'm like I know exactly
who that is
I know that they're a video game and
then I met hex a little later and he
explained like no this is teams
[ __ ] got jerseys and then I
went to the thing and now I realize like
jerseys at home once I saw that
somebody's wrapping your jersey you are
a [ __ ] athlete at that point I don't
care if it's you're happy with your
hands then all right trust me I'm for
listening but I want to go call him an
athlete dude I'm gonna say it but I hear
you but like even fools that do pro Tech
decking hey that can you do it then [ __ ]
off
you're a digital Africa if somebody told
me that you're a pro smoke a weed the
day I got paid to do a weed video and I
was uh what do you want to do just smoke
this tell me I like it like my heart
just got remember in the Grinch when he
turns good that's how I felt like if I
got paid to smoke weed today like my
life's different I remember that they're
exactly professional competitors but
it's just like I don't know about the
word athlete because I've been Esports
I'm just trying to like [ __ ] that's what
it's called as soon as I saw jerseys and
fools like this thanks they're competing
they put so much time into that like
well like it's like any other sport or
anything you'd have to they put in that
maybe more no no honestly more because
like their bodies can handle you can't
I just feel like you can't play
basketball or football for 16 hours a
day but you can play card for 16 hours
so in terms of time obviously it like
taxes your body more but you're also
getting in better teams than your body
can handle more with like sports and
[ __ ] but like I don't know but it is a
lot of time yes we're at a time where
they're obviously real competitors yeah
they're real like my cousin what do you
want to do I want to play professional
uh Esports I'm like well this is a real
thing this is real you can make [ __ ]
money I hope you do it yeah you don't
even need to be like you don't even need
to have like a following it doesn't even
matter it's like you know what I mean
you don't even need to go that route if
you don't want to be a country you
become a pro but it's just a lot of
[ __ ] time dude but what a time if you
already love it and that's what you want
to do it's like it exists you know what
I mean I love it dude well you pave in
the way man and now you're 10 years deep
yeah it's been nice a decade deep me
talking to my eight-year-old Like Son
we're gonna get you playing video games
get your [ __ ] and start editing all
right start freestyling or something I'm
telling you dude you can you make it
it's funny how parents like want their
kids to play games now it's weird huh
it's wild it's [ __ ] especially when
your kid's good it's like yo he's got an
arm on him huh now it's like do you know
what he how many kills he gets in a
[ __ ] lot
it's the whole different world man I
love it
um so all right so from starting off I
never ever ever would I have I smoked
tobacco got light-headed in my podcast
first so podcast my life first there it
is thank you for that thank you for
coming on the show man I know it's been
a minute how long you've been here well
two
all right that was quick thank you so
much for being here man um everybody can
get your weed here in La I know that yes
sir right and absolutely and delivery
services too they don't got to go to the
store you can still get it online too is
there I mean they're not going to search
every store and go do you have things
I'm pretty sure on our website on
recovery.io so that's rcvry.io you can
go like okay
rcvry.com yeah no it's just that dot IO
dot IO what's IO mean what the for sure
it's like wait hold up never heard of
that [ __ ] yeah pretty sure it's input
output
I don't even know what that is I'm
pretty sure it's input output bro I
learned emails about set or not be
[ __ ] interface something I'm pretty
sure it's input output all right correct
you're right all right there you go so
everyone go there and they can see where
you actually have your locations okay
and then for everyone else where can
they find you at were you are you
streaming doing your thing
I'll be there be there no I'm saying be
there just face rain yeah that's not
it's like all my YouTube and [ __ ] but
like I just have I'm still like getting
back into being active and [ __ ] so I'm
saying like on YouTube and [ __ ] mostly
though okay yeah just so because
everybody's always going to ask like
where can I find it where can I because
you know right now sorry what was the
question where am I gonna be no like
where can people find you like where if
they can come support you be in the
Stream hop in like no I don't stream
that much I only stream for a little bit
like when I was like super wheelchair
because like I just needed you know so
yeah I got you so where can you putting
out videos you're still doing your thing
YouTube yeah
mostly been on Instagram if anything but
yeah same thing you have one post man
yeah
ah
follow me on Instagram just cherish the
[ __ ] into that post man like it's sick
keep running that one back all right
that's fine that's fine also real quick
what car is that McLaren yeah all right
we had it for like five years though
it's flat Story Time orange that's my
[ __ ] so I saw that oars like oh
I'm so against like buying cars like
that no no they're awesome but it's like
just an OD amount because yeah there's
so many things you got to get first
before like a [ __ ] sick ass car like
I don't know yeah a lot of things should
take priority wait did you just buy it
outright yes I didn't have credit back
then so I just kept buying cars cash
that's why you're like I don't know if I
should do that you painted cash yeah we
make payments over here all right guys
normal guys if I didn't have credit
though I was a kid I just like I wanted
it yeah [ __ ] it dude who else can as a
kid go I'm gonna buy that one mom you're
retired we're getting McLaren yeah like
hey man if any can take anything away
from that it's that it's now a real
thing and if you're out there there's a
lot of people out there doing it
hopefully you come back to see this
video and go it's [ __ ] possible
that's what it's all shout out to your
principal yeah
you've seen him since
no and I don't know if he's alive which
is so sad at both times I was back in
Canada I tried to like call that school
that he worked at because he left my
school went to a different school first
time I called they said he wasn't there
and then when I called again the next
time I went back in Canada because I
kept trying to like reach him they said
like yeah he hasn't been back because
like he's like in the hospital for like
his heart damn it's I don't know
well if you still never got home talk to
him that's that's what I'm saying that'd
be so cool like thank you fool I know I
know it's always nice man but thank you
for being here I appreciate it I can't
believe you've been here for two hours
so thank you appreciate it guys it's
been the dope usual podcast thank you so
much for watching from Marty faze rain
and I have a dope ass day yes sir boom
foreign
[Music]